hi this is an alt shift x live stream to
talk about house of the dragon episode
four we are doing one of these live
streams right after each episode of
house of the dragon plus a edited
explained video later in the week around
friday so like and subscribe
and uh my god this truly was an episode
of of terrible decisions i don't think
there's a single character this episode
who did not make a
catastrophically bad decision
damon uh and
uh had a bit of a public makeout session
in a
in a brothel
and then rhaenyra decided to have sex
with kristen cole
the kingsguard who is sworn to secrecy a
sworn to chastity rather uh he's risking
his life by having sex with the princess
of king viserys banished damon again
and also
fired his hand otto hightower
um alison
confronted rhaenyra in the godswood and
rhaenyra lied to her
to the girl who had once been her best
friend
uh a lie which you know
i could see coming back to bite her
i like this last line in the episode
which is
it will rid you of any unwanted
consequences i feel like this episode is
all about setting up
unwanted consequences
of horrifically bad decisions
so uh my god there's a lot to talk about
so let's get into it this stream will
have no spoilers for future episodes of
house of the dragon we'll just talk
about uh the show so far and compared to
the books and compared to the rest of
the story
uh because there is some interesting
like contrasts and similarities with
with what goes on in the books because
if you think that there was a lot of you
know sex and secret affairs and rumors
about you know and gossip about sex in
this episode the books have the books
have twice as much
uh so we'll discuss that as well
um
thanks for the super chat from
bars and bolts who says do you think
that was earl grey
so we saw that uh grand maester melos
brought a tea to princess rhaenyra that
he said would um
save her from unwanted consequences so
this is called moon tea
um and it's something that induces a
period in women so it like prevents
pregnancy so this is like westerosi
plan b pill
um and the maester talks about how you
know he wants to
um he brewed it very carefully so that
it wouldn't have any like
impact on her health because moon tea
can be dangerous so in the books
if i'm remembering this rightly so lisa
aaron
who was the husband of
john aaron and she's the one who threw
people out the moon door and so on and
she got killed by littlefinger in season
four
lysa aaron had sex uh with littlefinger
when she was young and her father forced
her to have moon tea to prevent her from
getting pregnant but the moon t uh
affected her body badly and
it's it seems as though the moon t
damaged a reproductive system so that
she wasn't able to have
um children very well like she had a
bunch of miscarriages and stuff
um and uh sweet robin john aaron was the
product of uh of her and uh yeah it's uh
speculated that the moon t did not do
her any uh favors there
um so yeah we'll talk about that more in
the explained video as well but yeah
that's what the moon t was uh thanks for
the super chat from jacob who says uh
the ad the actor for otto rhys fans is
so good made me feel bad for otto yeah i
think the performance um from otto was
really good because otto
otto told viserys that princess rhaenyra
hooked up with daemon
and otto has a lot to gain from saying
that because otto wants his grandson
baby aegon to be aired to the throne
instead of rhaenyra so like it's good
for otto to make rhaenyra look bad and
to compromise rhaenyra but you really
can see on otto's face that he feels
very uncomfortable like telling viserys
about this um and when viserys fires
otto you know
we do feel bad for otto i think
um like we saw last episode how otto was
under pressure from his big brother
herbert and so you sort of wonder you
know how much is otto acting out of his
own ambition and how much is he acting
out of obligation for his family you
know otto comes from one of the richest
most powerful families in the realm and
i think he's got a lot of responsibility
to you know
further his family's interests and you
know i really like how viserys tells him
that he just tell viserys just says to
otto's face like you are acting by your
own ambitions i don't trust you anymore
um
it's all kind of true but um
i wonder if viserys is making the best
decision here
um
thanks for the super chat from evan who
said i really enjoyed the conversation
between viserys and otto such a powerful
scene yeah i thought it was really well
acted
thanks for the super chat from uh saint
who regrettably uses the word targusi
thanks for the super chat from too much
gaming who says that was totally
mushroom in the preview for next week
we'll have a look at the preview shortly
i mean i did like the mamas scene we had
these like street performers who were
doing a play about um like the small
folks perception of
um current political events this guy
kind of reminded me of mushroom mushroom
is a character in the fire and blood
book who's a jester and he's one of the
historical sources and he
he claims that all these people had sex
with other people like his version of
this story that we're watching is a lot
more salacious
than uh what the maesters write and so
mushroom has an entirely different story
about what went down between rhaenyra
and daemon
in this episode so according to mushroom
mushroom says that
mushroom says that rhaenyra had the hots
for kristin cole the kingsguard knight
and
so
her plan to hook up with kristen
was to get sex lessons from damon
so mushroom describes in great detail
how rhaenyra and daemon would fly off on
their dragons and go to secluded islands
in blackwater bay uh where they would uh
where rhaenyra was instructed in the
womanly arts by damon and they were like
just
uh finagling each other all day uh to
train rhaenyra to be good at sex and
then rhaenyra came on to kristen and
then kristen rejected rhaenyra according
to mushroom um and and that was the
scandal that happened like there's all
these different versions of what the
historians think went down between
rhaenyra and daemon and kristen but what
we saw in this episode was that rhaenyra
went out to a brothel with damon they
sort of made out a bit and it looks like
damon like couldn't get it up like he
looked like sexually impotent in this
episode that's what they talked about in
the inside the episode
which is interesting because like sexual
failure of different kinds are connected
to moral failure in a song of ice and
fire sometimes like king maegor the
cruel
was um was the king before jaehaerys
here's um he has a wonderful
bit of artwork actually i'm not i'm not
sure i can show uh i might have to zoom
up here uh this is king maegor
seen here licking blood off of the sword
blackfyre this artwork is by chili
ravenheart and king maegor in the books
uh he married six wives um here's some
more artwork by chili chili raven art he
married six wives because he was trying
to father a child he was trying to
create a baby and he couldn't get any of
these women pregnant and he kept saying
he kept blaming the women he kept saying
oh this woman is barren so that's why i
need to marry another woman
um and
maegor was an evil dude it's quite
possible that he was a zombie actually
he sort of was quite close to dying at
one point
um and it seems as though uh his mother
visenya and this sort of witch character
like resurrected him so it's possible
the reason why he couldn't impregnate
anyone was because he was a little bit
of a zombie is i think the implication
anyway this is sort of off topic but um
my point is that in a song of ice and
fire sometimes the failure to reproduce
is connected to being evil or being sort
of
corrupt in some way which itself is a
whole count of worms but my point is
that you know damon's failure
to perform sexually with rhaenyra might
be a sort of a symbol about his sort of
moral failure like he's a bad dude in
some sense um
i mean i really like the in-house of the
dragon they are leaning on the sort of
symbolism and the um superstition
aspects of it like the white heart last
episode they're really leaning into that
symbolism which i think is really fun
uh thanks to super chat from person and
from lance lance says did the queen's
message that cole delivered
inadvertently tell him that he was a
rebound if so
could that plant the seed for future
resentment yeah so kristen cole
delivered a message to rhaenyra so are
you saying that maybe kristen
found out
that
rhaenyra
allegedly hooked up with damon and you
think that kristen might be mad that
rainier hooked up with daemon yeah maybe
i mean i i did enjoy um those shots
later on of
um
rainier hanging out with damon and
seeing damon after having had sex with
him like the awkwardness the discomfort
on uh kristen's face
uh was so apparent um because obviously
as a kingsguard knight you are not meant
to have sex you are sworn to chastity
just like the night's watch and the
maesters and stuff um it is a it is a
big no-no to have sex when you're on the
king's guard especially when you are
having sex with the princess of the
realm and the heir to the throne uh sir
kristen could very easily have his head
cut off for having had sex with rhaenyra
that there was a recent controversy um
under the old king jiharis there was
this kingsguard fella called lucamor the
lusty
and it was found out that this
kingsguard guy he not only uh broke his
vows and had sex he actually had
three wives
and a bunch of children this kingsguard
guy secretly
got married three times and had a bunch
of kids
and so he like confessed to king jahirus
like oh i'm so sorry for breaking my
vows and having all these kids um and he
got executed for it i think um so you
know that there's a long history of
kingsguard people breaking their vows
and it's always a bad idea so like
kristin is terrified at this point i
think
um and it's gonna be really interesting
to see what their vibe is in the future
um because it was interesting like you
know rhaenyra seemed sort of playful
with kristen after they had had sex
um maybe rainier doesn't fully
understand um how
potentially dangerous this is
uh unsourced in the la in the super chat
says kristen deserves better than being
a side piece
yeah well i wonder you know how rainier
sees kristin now like like is rainier
are going to continue to want to um hook
up with kristen is she going to want to
get with damon after she got a taste of
her
uncle
uh my god it's
so much [ __ ] up relationships
thanks for the super chat from jake and
from courtney courtney says is there
anything to be said for rhaenyra being
in a greenish outfit and alicent in a
black red outfit when they're talking in
the godswood there may well be i mean
all the colors and outfits are always
very important um like i like how
alison's outfit
is looking very targaryenny like there
are these dragon heads on her dress and
her shoulders look very sort of like
proud and regal almost like dragon wings
or something um and her prior outfit
here in the godswood this is a very
targaryan outfit with the black and red
so alison is is wearing the clothes of a
targaryen queen you know
whereas rhaenyra is still so often
wearing yellow and i think rhaenyra you
know rhaenyra not wearing black and red
sort of suggests that she's not fully
taking on the role of a targaryen heir i
mean we mentioned in the previous video
that rhaenyra rhaenyra is really not
acting like a politician rhaenyra is not
acting like the heir to the throne um at
least not yet like you know she's just
sort of mucking around riding into the
forest macking with her uncle she's not
behaving like a proper politician and
that contrasts with allison who is who
is so acting like a proper politician
and you know she hates it like they they
showed us how lonely and sad alison is
this episode like she feels trapped she
doesn't have any friends like she's got
this gross old man having sex with her
um that was so disturbing like the sex
scene between allison and viserys where
viserys had all of these
visible like wounds and sores on his
body from from the throne and like
infections like this this man is
rotting and while and he's having sex
with allison and yeah so you know and i
think it's really interesting
how allison
uh in this episode was sort of you know
defending oh you know it's not so bad
being a princess is not so bad being a
queen like you know this is the way it
is and we've got to just make the best
of it and it's like because she's
trapped in this system you know she has
kids now she has two kids now we saw a
daughter allison now has a baby daughter
as well as a baby son aegon um so you
know she's she's locked into the system
now so all she can do is make the best
of this relationship with viserys and i
think rhaenyra sees that and rhaenyra
does not want to get locked in to some
uncomfortable
relationship trapped in a castle like
allison is and rhaenyra also talks this
episode about how she doesn't want to
die in childbirth
you know rhaenyra's mother emma died in
childbirth that was very traumatic for
rainer so i think she's afraid of the
same thing happening to her if she gets
married um and uh rhaenyra's grandmother
reina sorry daela targaryen also died in
childbirth so there's a long legacy of
you know
marriage leading to death and she's
afraid of that
um
thanks for the super chat from
rahman who says did otto use his press
rights to not reveal the source yeah
that was funny when uh when
otto and viserys were talking and
viserys wanted to know
who told
uh otto about rainier are having sex
with damon
and otto refused to reveal his sources
you've got to protect your sources when
you're when you're uh handed the king
there's no uh master of whisperers at
the moment which is interesting like
remember in game of thrones varys was
the spy master the master of whisperers
and so he had all these little birds who
were who were spying on things
but this time we saw this little boy who
reported on uh rainier and damon to um
to otto and then to the king and that
little boy was working for
missouri the white worm uh who is you
know daemon's uh on and off lover and i
thought it was yeah so here's this
little boy
um who we see
it seems as though the boy is giving
missouri money i'm not sure why missouri
is taking money from the street urchin
um i feel like missouri should be paying
the urchin but the point is that that
boy is spying for missouri and i thought
it was really interesting that missouri
told otto
that
damon slept with rhaenyra which
undermines daemon and gets him banished
um i wonder if missouri is trying to
like get back at daemon for
you know not protecting her like he
promised to because like this is you
know damon's been off fighting in the
step stones for a year or two um
i think missouri is angry at damon i
mean mazzaria calls herself a protector
of damon in that you know she gave him
somewhere to crash when he was wasted
um but i think missouri is like acting
against
uh damon by telling otto about hooking
up with rhaenyra that's curious to me
um
otto's money yeah you're saying that
otto paid missouri for the information
yeah i i guess that
i guess that is it yeah i i also find it
confusing that she's working with otto
um maybe she is like a unofficial master
of whisperers for otto yeah i mean they
call her a white worm she's uh she she's
a worm she is corrupt you know she's
pretending to be damon's friend but
she's really not
which is um yeah super interesting
yeah yeah that makes sense
um oh yeah it should say
episode four on the top we can uh we can
fix that real quick
let's make a little text box
and let's make it say
four
and let's uh put that
uh
yeah yeah whatever well it's meant to be
four
yeah sorry whatever um so what else
happened thanks for the super chat from
jude who says always miss the live
stream just wanted to join in thanks for
the super chat from
brian who says the show's bias against
the grains continues otto equals morally
bankrupt politician rhaenyra equals
blameless protagonist who is a victim of
society
i don't really agree like
there
there were
a lot of moments in this episode and in
the previous episode
of people telling reiner that she's
making bad choices
um like you know that like right like
alison was telling rhaenyra in the
godswood that you know you're being sort
of ungrateful
to viserys and like kristin in the
previous episode told rainer hey like
you're a princess like people would
gladly trade places with you you have it
really good you're in a position of
privilege
um and i think it's pretty obvious that
rhaenyra is sort of putting kristen a
really bad decision i mean you know it
was kristin's decision to have sex with
her but um i don't think this episode
and this show is being entirely
sympathetic to rhaenyra she is like a
protagonist like she's the protagonist i
think more than anyone else but rhaenyra
is not totally blameless here i don't
think um but you know something they do
emphasize is definitely like the
unfairness and the hypocrisy that men
can have sex with whoever they want but
women are not allowed to and women are
considered to be sullied and you know
unmarriageable if they've lost their
virginity or whatever
um
thanks for the super chat from joshua
who says a princess removing a knight's
armor is top tier romance yeah i mean
look it would be a lot more romantic if
she wasn't so young i think rainier is
meant to be like 18
at this point she's even younger in the
books um it's probably a good thing that
they aged up the characters
uh
and um thanks for the super chat from c
who says what do you think was going on
in circles mind
yeah kristen i well kristen knows how
dangerous it is for him to have sex as a
king's god so i think he knows that he's
made a bad mistake
thanks for a super chat from gabriella
who says is this the accurate telling
the book was written by mushroom and the
maester but i thought cole rejected her
yeah well there yeah as i said there are
lots of different accounts of what
really happened here um
and
in some of the accounts kristin cole
rejected um brain era but there are
there are various versions of what
happened
thanks for the super chat from joe who
said did damon deliberately make the
make out session public to make her
position less stable
yeah i thought that was very interesting
um so
so when rhaenyra and damon were going
out and hanging out with the common
people and then going to the brothel
rhaenyra was wearing this this rather
fetching beanie to hide her targaryen
blonde hair but daemon took off her hat
when they went into the brothel before
they started making out um so yeah i
think daemon was deliberately making
rhaenyra no longer anonymous
so that people would know that he hooked
up with rhaenyra like he took her to
like a semi-public place to do this he
could have gone somewhere private but
he took off her disguise and did it in
public because i think that you know
later on damon said to king viserys hey
let me marry rhaenyra and you know we
will be the people on the throne um
so i think that part of damon's
motivation for hooking up with rhaenyra
was that he wanted to force viserys to
let him marry her um
i think that viserys is right that to
some extent damon is using rhaenyra for
political
aim and for political ambition
um because if it becomes known that
damon and rhaenyra had sex then other
people aren't going to want to marry her
and it might be seen as necessary to
marry damon to rhaenyra
um
so yeah
this was a political act that damon was
using rhaenyra for i think for sure
thanks for the super chat from potsdam
who says
surprised by the d handing of otto he
came off as very innocent in that scene
yeah i think they're doing a great job
of giving otto some layers
thanks for the super chat from serena
who says wondering if she has to douse
the coal in her furnace
with that tea yeah
yes metaphorically that is what she's
doing with the moon tea it induces a
period so that she won't get pregnant
uh thanks for the super chat from flavor
who says love seeing the blackwood and
bracken hostility yeah um we we have not
gotten to see the blackwoods and the
brackens in the original tv show so far
um so you know we had this
scene where rhaenyra was sitting in what
i believe is storm's end to the ancient
castle of the baratheons one of the
strongest castles in the realm and we've
never seen that in the original show but
we've got this long procession of lords
who are presenting themselves to
rhaenyra and saying hey you should marry
me and then rhaenyra keeps going swipe
left swipe left swipe left it's like
those click bait uh tinder in real life
videos she's choosing who she wants to
marry and these are the eligible
bachelors of westeros and so she sees
that you know most of them are these
crotchety old men who she has no
interest in
uh but then we get this young boy who is
a brac
sorry is a blackwood the blackwoods are
super cool because they are a family in
the riverlands who worship the old gods
uh which are mostly only worshipped in
the north
the lord of uh
raven tree hall in the time of the game
of thrones books is uh titos blackwood
who has an incredibly cool cloak made
out of raven feathers
um and the black woods are just just
generally just straight up cool dudes um
bloodraven was half blackwood uh who's
one of the most mysterious characters in
the series but the blackwoods have an
ancient rivalry with this house called
the brackens
um and house bracken is also in the
riverlands they don't worship the old
gods but they have this like ancient
ancient
uh grudge and they've been killing each
other for ages so it's pretty
fun
that this uh this bracken guy kept
insulting the blackwood guy which is
just that's just what black woods and
brackens do uh and then they just fought
a jewel for rain hero just in the middle
of storm's end out of nowhere um
he was being such a dick that bracken
guy uh but then the blackwood got his
revenge by fighting against the
uh bracken and killing him i don't know
if he was meant to be like the lord of
of stonehedge is it stonehenge
that the bracken's rule
but this blackwood kid just kills a
bracken which again seems like a sort of
a wildly violent thing to happen on a
formal occasion
it's a bit like in episode one of house
of the dragon when all of those knights
just started murdering each other in the
middle of the tournament like that's not
normally okay
i i guess like what they might be going
for with all the random violence in
house of the dragon is that you know
just like rhaenys was saying in episode
one this is a time full of
pent-up aggressions like it's been a
peaceful realm for like a while now and
i think there's a lot of pent-up
violence and aggression and sexuality
and people want to get out and swing
swords and sow seeds and young dumb and
full of all sorts of stuff and um i
think that's why some of this violence
is happening it's like this tension it's
like this bubbling
energy that wants to be let out um it's
like something that frank herbert might
have written
um so yeah it's very cool to see the
black woods and the brackens um and it's
good to see the black woods come out on
top
thanks for the super chat and also i i
would note that this um this like
procession of you know rain era touring
the kingdoms and getting to choose from
all of the eligible bachelors
lined up for her this is evocative of
something that happens later on in the
fire and blood book and again i i won't
spoil anything but there is a king
later on far later on in the story who
who has a similar event where
he's single and ready to mingle so he
gets all of these eligible bachelorettes
from all around the realm there's like
there's like a thousand girls who all
line up in front of the iron throne and
uh the king
just sort of meets them one by one and
decides which one he wants to marry and
it's described as a cattle show
in the books just like the absurdity of
this long queue of of single women who
the king is choosing from and so they've
um they're doing a similar thing for
rain year right here but rhaenyra gets
sick of it because she's not interested
in all of these old men and boys and so
she sails home to king's landing um
which is
uh
i mean you'd think that they could have
sent a few hot people right i mean why
didn't some of these lords send some of
their like you know hot suns the heirs
to the houses um
surely they could have found someone who
rainier might have been attracted to
this this guy here by the way is
borroman baratheon he's the lord of
storm's end he's an ancestor of king
bobby b baratheon and renly and stannis
um and so he's an important powerful
lord
thanks for the super chat from pulsar
who says i like how viserys is finally
doing what is best for the realm instead
of trying to make everyone happy
yeah
yeah well
i mean it might make sense for viserys
to fire otto like
like it is true that otto sometimes acts
in the interests of
uh his family instead of in the
interests of the realm um but i i think
it might have been a mistake for viserys
to
make otto into an enemy you know like he
was so aggressive to otto and telling
him that um
you know i i think it would have been
smart if viserys was a bit more
diplomatic
when he fired otto
um
because you want otto to be a friend
otto is still a very
important and powerful person and he is
the
father of um
allison his wife you know do you really
want to piss off your father-in-law that
much
yeah you gotta sort of it's better to
have him as a friend i would think
i'll just put the four over here so that
we don't have the wrong bloody number
there we go
all right
that's better thanks for the super chat
from ben who says in game of thrones
they say the dragons became dog-sized
when does that happen they are still big
200 years before
um yeah so i don't think this is a
spoiler but um
there is this idea that when dragons are
kept in captivity they become smaller
and weaker so we were told that in the
dragon pit in game of thrones season
seven daenerys told jon snow that when
they started keeping dragons in the
dragon pit the dragons sort of stopped
being as big and powerful um and
we will learn more about like how all of
that goes down and it's i mean it still
is mysterious i mean there there's some
characters in the books who claim that
there's a maester conspiracy against the
dragons so some people think that maybe
the maesters poisoned the dragons or
something um
and you know there's also this idea that
daenerys in the main books she keeps her
dragons rhaegal and viserion locked away
under marine
and as a result they are not as large as
her main dragon drogon so yeah it is
sort of supported in the text that
locking the dragons indoors
tends to make them not grow as large but
we're going to learn a lot more about
the dragons as we go along
thanks for the super chat from v who
says do you think the ending
specifically when the maester talks
about the targaryens birthing monstrous
things if the moon t is weak confirms
dragonmorph theory
uh well the maester did not mention
dragon babies i don't think but yeah
there is a history of targaryens giving
birth to like deformed dragon like
babies on occasion like daenerys does in
book one
her stillborn baby rhaego
um
dragonmorph theory i don't know what you
mean by dragonmoth i mean you know there
certainly is the idea that targaryens
literally have the blood of dragons like
they might have been the result of
valyrian blood magic hybridization
experiments or something crazy like that
um so i think it does make a lot of
sense actually there is some sort of
biological dna connection between
dragons and targaryens and some of their
birth deformities might be related to
that
uh thanks to the super chat from caitlin
who says do you think daemon is using
rhaenyra or does he love her
so yeah i think that um
there is a real connection and a real
attraction between daemon and rhaenyra i
mean we saw that since
um episode one
of house of the dragon you know when
um viserys when damon gave rhaenyra this
necklace you know that was this sort of
intimate moment between them
um so i think there is like a real
attraction and a real connection i mean
you can certainly wonder if daemon is
like grooming rhaenyra or if he's like
planning to
want to hook up with her at some point
and so he's got sort of impure
motivations and it's like an abusive
thing like because of the gap in power
and because of the gap in age
um and you know like like the situation
that damon put rhaenyra in in the
brothel um you know she talked about how
damon was her escort and she feel like
she didn't have a lot of choice about
where she went or what she did so
there's definitely like a nasty
undercurrent to it
maybe not even an undercurrent it's a
it's a whole nasty situation i think
um and damon is is using her politically
you know because marrying the heir to
the throne uh would be a way for daemon
to get power potentially
um but i think on top of that you know
damon is someone who is seeking
validation and is seeking
um a connection with people and it seems
as though you know he seems to have lost
he seems to have lost that connection
with his brother viserys it doesn't seem
as though daemon is seeking viserys's
validation so much anymore so i think on
some level daemon is seeking validation
from rhaenyra uh which might lead to
some very unhealthy relationships
my god everyone makes bad decisions this
episode so yeah look i i think it's
complicated between daemon and rhaenyra
but it's uh it's it's not what you'd
call a wholesome model of
a good relationship uh thanks for the
super chat from james who says was
alison brewing sweet sleep is that why
she's not harming herself now
also glad to see what black woods and
brackens doing what they do best i don't
know what you mean about allison harming
herself i mean one thing that is
interesting is that you know it's very
much the maester who brings moon tea to
rainier and we've seen that grand
maester melos has been working closely
with otto
so i wonder if the high towers
like sent the moon tea for rhaenyra
because because if rhaenyra gave birth
to a son
that would potentially make rhaenyra's
claim to the throne stronger
like that's something they talked about
at the great council of harrenhal when
they talked about rhaenys targaryen
potentially being queen
the fact that rainey's had a male heir
lenore was considered a point in her
favor her favor if you have a male heir
that means that um you ha you have a
succession from you you know so it makes
you a better claimant to the throne
um some people might even think that you
know like if rhaenyra had a son
by damon like that would combine the
claims like some people think that
daemon should be the heir to the throne
some people think rhaenyra should be the
head of the throne if damon and rhaenyra
have a son that son would combine damon
and rhaenyra's claims
so yeah i think it's possible that the
hightowers might want
rhaenyra to
not have that child they might want to
prevent that child
because that child could replace
alison's baby aegon as the strongest
claimant to the throne for sure
um so you know so much of what this show
is about is about the
connectedness of the biological and the
political like women's bodies as a
political object
because who's boning who is of
critical importance to the political
stability of the realm you know and i
think that's why fundamentally
this medieval royal family drama
i think the reason why game of thrones
is such a engaging and and fun and
dramatic and colorful story is because
um
the structure of a royal family
makes intimate personal connections
massively important it it it makes it
important at scale you know at the scale
of realms or the scale of kingdoms
kingdoms rise and fall
based on who dicks who
you know so i think that's sort of what
makes
uh house of the dragons so cool
uh thanks for the super chat from will
who says kristen going to be hated in
future episodes now yeah kristen kristen
[ __ ] up you should not bone the
princess thanks for the super chat from
jmo who said did you notice the dudes
wearing the spiral striped outfits did
you mean those uh mamas who um
who rhaenyra and damon ran past those
those street performers yeah they looked
funny thanks for the super chat from
brandon who says love your videos
especially this new series thank you
thank you brandon thanks for the super
chat from argo who says that spy boy was
paid by mazzaria planned by damon no i
don't think that was planned by damon i
think that yeah i think that the boy was
paid
um
i think that the boy was paid by otto to
pay mazzaria it looks as though mazaria
was informing for um
otto
thanks for the super chat from nick who
says benjicott blackwood sighting
uh yeah so there are some specific
blackwood characters in the books i
i think that they said he was someone
else the the blackwood boy i don't think
he's benjicot
did they introduce his name
did they say his name
yeah he i guess he i guess that could be
benji got blackwood but you know we will
we'll find out in the future
thanks for the super chat from gabriella
who said i feel like the female director
didn't hit the mark had no clue dude
couldn't get hard honestly thought he
reconsidered due to her heavy eye
contact
yeah so in the inside the episode they
said that like damon couldn't get it up
and that's why he didn't have sex with
rhaenyra
um whereas yeah like i had the same
impression in the episode itself that
damon just like chose not to have sex
with with rhaenyra because he sort of
realized it was a bad idea
um but in the inside the episode they
were saying like damon like wanted to
but couldn't which is really interesting
because like they did a similar thing in
episode one when damon was having sex
with mazaria but like he couldn't come
or like he couldn't finish or whatever
um so you know damon's like sexual
frustration which i think is a really
good metaphor for daemon's character
because daemon is someone who just uh
can't get no satisfaction um he just
feels like he can't get what he wants
and he can't get release and he's got
all of this
energy that's just pent up just like all
of those knights killing each other you
know he'd all this violence and all this
chaotic energy because he just can't
satisfy himself you know which you know
maybe that's gross but i think it's a
good analogy for for what's going on
with daemon
um thanks for the super chat from
tsukariyari who says the sly little
sarah reference when they talk about
jiharis's response to rainier's actions
oh cool i didn't catch that sarah
targaryen was a daughter of jiharis
who similar to rhaenyra had a bunch of
like secret scandalous sexual exploits
and then she ran off to a brothel and uh
jahiris really failed to reconcile with
her and um so she
fathered a bunch of bastards off on the
east and and never came back
thanks for the super chat from andrew
who says what are the chances of you
uploading your
dotd explainer to nebula because i
absolutely would pay for a subscription
to see that again
d-o-t-d what is d-o-t-d are you trying
to say house of the dragon all of the
ultra fx videos are on nebula um so not
sure what you mean thanks for the super
chat from jim who says the shots made it
look like a fantasy as it was cutting
back and forth between nearly making out
and then they turned away
um
yeah damon and ra rhaenyra did not
actually have sex they just uh got
warmed up and then rhaenyra went off to
kristen cole thanks for the super chat
from cie who says digging the more muted
color palette color palette and general
cinematography
yeah i mean certainly compared to other
episodes this one was a bit more of a
dark and moody
um episode compared to like the splendor
of the tournaments and stuff i i guess
it was you'd call it an action light
episode because you know there was no
violence in this episode there was just
a bunch of sex
um i thought it was funny that you know
while rhaenyra was on the boat
back to king's landing
uh damon swooped over
swooped over the ship on his dragon
caraxies just because he's he's that
kind of guy and he wants to cause a
ruckus and he wants to get attention so
he like swoops the ship and almost
injured rhaenyra um and i feel like they
did that mostly for the trailers because
a bunch of the house of the dragon
trailers have showed that shot of
karaxi's swooping on the ship and making
it rock um it doesn't really lead to
anything like it's a pretty
inconsequential moment but they got to
use that dramatic shock shot in the
previews i feel like the show is afraid
of not having any action in the episodes
for fear that people will lose interest
but um i i think i think that some of
the most interesting stuff in this show
is just the conversations and the
relationships and the scandalous drama
that happens i don't think they need
dragons in every single episode
thanks for the super chat from maura kia
who says allison was coming off awfully
hypocritical when confronting rhaenyra
um yeah so
it it is interesting isn't it like why
was alison so angry at rhaenyra like i
feel like there might be an element of
envy here like alison is angry that
rhaenyra gets to go off and have fun and
leave the red keep and have sex with
whoever she wants because that is all
the freedom that alison does not have
and i do really you know it seems so
apparent to me that you know part of
allison's anger is that you know she is
trapped in this ugly marriage with
viserys and she has kids now so it's
like she can't run away from this now
you know this is
this is inescapable for her this
situation that she's in and i think that
you know because she's bought into this
relationship um she feels a lot of like
she i think she might be projecting a
lot of anger on to rhaenyra
um
you might i guess you might call it
internalized misogyny or something um
but it's so tragic that rhaenyra is in a
situation where she
she lies to alison like just when they
had started to be friends again like
they had just had this moment in the
godswood where they really started sort
of reconnecting and let's be friends
again but then right after rhaenyra lies
to alice and i mean like you know milly
alcock the actor in the inside the
episode said that ah rhaenyra
technically didn't lie because you know
rhaenyra only swore that she didn't have
sex with damon and you know technically
rhaenyra did not have sex with damon she
had sex with kristin cole so it's fine
um but you know i think that alison if
she finds out that rhaenyra you know
lied about not having sex that night um
that might um
that might make alison feel betrayed
and of course you know they talk about
how much it sucks that it's such a
terrible crime for a girl to have sex
but you know viserys and damon were
talking about um having sex all the time
when they were younger um at brothels
and stuff and that's just a-okay i liked
seeing sort of the brotherly the
brotherly bond between damon and viserys
being explored like the books talk about
how um viserys
really had fond memories about growing
up with damon and how damon was such
like a fun adventurous boy when when
they were kids growing up and so that's
a big part of why viserys is
why viserys puts up with so much of
daemon's [ __ ] for so long is that
you know damon sort of represents
viserys's childhood and like a more
carefree time
um and i think in a way you know viserys
is probably envious of damon like damon
has so much freedom compared to viserys
and viserys hates the responsibilities
that he has you know i think even this
shot is such a funny shot like this this
is such a awkward facial expression that
viserys has right now because he's
trying to frown he's trying to he's
trying to be stern like a king but he's
also smiling because he likes his
brother you know so
even this uncomfortable face i feel like
it says a lot about viserys's character
because he is simultaneously
trying to be a politician but wanting to
be a brother at the same time you know
viserys is so so conflicted
um
the the arrival this scene is less
dramatic than it is in the book so i
wonder if they might
i i yeah i guess they've just changed it
because in the books um damon returns
from the stepstones with his crown of
this of the narrow sea he he swoops down
on dragonback during a tournament he
just turns up unannounced in the middle
of a tournament and presents his brother
with his crown actually i think there
might be some um
i think there might be some artwork of
that yeah here we are
this is
this is some artwork by chase stone
of
this moment in the books um where damon
targaryen matt smith he swoops down on
keraxis and presents his
his crown of the narrow sea to viserys
this is how it's depicted um and i
suppose that there is meant to be
alicent
and that there is meant to be rhaenyra i
suppose in this artwork
but uh yeah it's interesting that they
they changed that like mostly they've
been very
faithful to the books um so far like
they've invented a lot of the details
because the book is very
very um
not detailed but yeah kind of a shame
that he didn't do that on karaxis in my
opinion
thanks for the super chat from star who
says
have you seen
anything related to witcher uh i'm not
really into the witcher but um maybe
someday thanks for the super chat from
sego who says since viserys has now cut
off his hand will the moral slash
physical corruption end yeah that's a
great question like um you know we've
seen viserys's
body break down progressively as the
series has gone on he cut his finger in
episode one and then in episode two he
lost two of the well his fingers were
rotting in episode two and then in
episode three he had to amputate two of
his fingers and now we see that you know
there's like sores all over his body and
stuff so you know this idea that his
hand is corrupt otto hightower is his
hand of the king um and now he tells
otto you know you're corrupt i'm cutting
you off i'm sending you away so um so
yeah maybe amputating his corrupt hand
will save his body
um but you know we've seen now that you
know like when he was having sex with
allison there were like sores and
gangrenous dark patches all over his
back so i fear that the corruption has
spread beyond his hand at this point
thanks for the super chat from clarence
who says do you think the christian
scene was meant to be seen as consensual
the scene felt very tonally disjointed
um i think it was pretty clear that like
i mean rhaenyra initiated it rhaenyra
kissed kristen and started pulling off
his armor and stuff
um i mean you know i don't know i don't
know how the consent works with like the
age gap and whatever but
um i think rhaenyra was clearly the
person who initiated this
um but it truly is like a horrifically
bad idea for kristen to break his vows
like it's treason to have sex with the
princess out of wedlock
um
and it's yeah it's just gonna cause a
lot of problems for the both of them and
i think they both knew it and that's
that's the whole forbidden love thing
you know i mean i think there was some
detectable um
sexual tension between kristen and
rhaenyra for a while now like back in
episode one rhaenyra had this
had this very thirsty smirk when she met
kristen cole um and then you know out at
the campfire and stuff you know that
there was some
chemistry between
rainier and kristen for a long time i
think so you know i don't think it's
shocking that they are into each other i
mean i mean it was so
interesting like you know even
when
when we started when um
when
rainier has said good night to kristen
and went to her bedroom to sleep for the
night um it's gonna be so uncomfortable
for kristen now standing outside the
bedroom of this girl he had sex with
um
knowing what happened and knowing the
potential consequences of it i mean
kristin
would have such strong feelings right
now no like if this gets found out he's
[ __ ] so he must be full of regret and
this is something that you know george
martin has played with in a song of ice
on fire like there's a character called
um aris oakheart in the books who hooks
up with ariane martell who's another
book only character
um
and they call him the the soiled the
soiled knight um because he has
symbolically dirtied his his white cloak
by having sex and breaking his vows i
mean it's no coincidence that like every
second bloody
you know social order in westeros is
sworn to chastity the maesters are sworn
to have no sex the night's watchers
sworn to have no sex the king's guard
are sworn to have no sex because george
martin loves that forbidden love the
forbidden fruit the forbidden desire and
he loves the
internal conflict that comes from that
the forbidden romance is always his
favorite like jon snow and egret you
know two sides of the wall montagues and
capulets
um
star-crossed lovers
um
so yeah he's all over that thanks for
the super chat from topher who says
we're teetering on the edge of comedy of
errors territory with this episode
uh yeah i i gotta agree like like
everyone is just making a terrible
decision um like
like you know rhaenyra hooking up with
damon i mean damon hooking up with
rainier rainier hooking up with kristen
uh viserys antagonizing damon and uh
viserys antagonizing otto
uh
rhaenyra and allison
uh
lying to each other and antagonizing
each other in the future you know could
be worse potentially
um mazaria seems to be working against
daemon because mazaria told otto about
damon hooking up with uh rhaenyra so
yeah i agree like everyone is just
creating drama with everybody else uh
welcome to house of the dragon this is
kind of what it's about
um
there's a lot of this there's a lot of
betrayal and scandal
thanks for the super chat from dylan uh
who asks is otto more like littlefinger
or like ned stark i think otto was
absolutely more like littlefinger than
ned stark i mean i i really really like
what they did by showing us otto with
his brother herbert um because that sort
of gave otto a sort of a long-suffering
vibe i mean we got that you know like in
the small council scenes with otto um
there were these moments where i mean
you know otto was trying to get rhaenyra
to behave herself and then you know
rhaenyra was giving otto all this back
back talk and i think otto had this sort
of
resigned to everyone disrespecting him
sort of vibe um like
and in the small council scene as well
like you know
damon was insulting
otto's dead wife to his face like damon
was mocking otto's dead wife and otto
just had to stand there and take it and
king viserys sided with damon mocking
otto over his dead wife so it's like you
know we have seen otto have to put up
with a lot of [ __ ]
um and i i think it you know i think
that they're doing a good job of making
otto
a bit sympathetic at the same time otto
is like a calculating ambitious dude who
is using his daughter alison his teenage
daughter um trying to get her to have
sex with the king for the political
advancement of his house so like he's
not a great guy
but i like that they're making him late
like people were asking like you know
is this series biased on one side or the
other and at least you know i mean it's
it's up to the viewer like you know who
you feel sympathetic to but i think
they're doing a pretty good job of
showing that both sides
um are making mistakes and have sort of
good sides and bad sides i mean i would
say that like you know viserys and
rhaenyra seem to have like good
intentions but but
but tiny little brains
like viserys and rhaenyra are both
making some like bad choices
um
but but they have good intentions
whereas i think like otto and alison
both come off as a bit manipulative but
i mean allison is sort of forced into
that situation by otto so you know i but
but you know damon damon is a [ __ ] i
mean damon is violent damon hooks up
with his teenage niece like i i think
damon is probably the most villainous
main character um but but you know
people may disagree and that's something
that george martin and ryan condell
talked about in all the press for this
show
people will have disappear different
opinions on who's good or who's bad
um
but at least the way i see it i think
damon and otto are certainly like the
most villainous characters
um and i i suppose rhaenyra and viserys
tend to be the more sympathetic but they
both make terrible choices and things
will continue to develop
thanks for the
super chat from el danger who says we
see a red and white dragon in the
preview
yeah um i think that's uh sea smoke and
melisse the dragons of lenore and
rhaenys
thanks for the super chat from avery who
was much enthused about the blackwood
versus bracken yeah there's um there's
gonna be more and more
uh
other houses involved in the story later
on so i think they're setting some
groundwork there
master yoda says what do you think about
the knife scene yeah let's talk about
the knife they talked again about
prophecy
um which is really interesting so you
know one of the great disappointments
for book fans of the original game of
thrones show
is that they really did not do justice
to the prophecy stuff
there are lots of different prophetic
dreams that people have like that you
know in the game of thrones books
there's this stuff about you know cersei
will be killed by her valonqar and
valonqa means little brother so people
think you know cersei thinks that tyrion
is going to kill her because of a
prophecy um but a lot of readers suspect
that jaime will be the one to kill her
um but of course in the show
the the villain that defeats cersei is
um is bricks
i mean no i mean the death of cersei
could have been worse in the game of
thrones show because i think that the
red keep collapsing on her was like a
symbol of her ambition for power
destroying her you know it was like
self-destruction but my point my point
is that there's a lot of prophecy stuff
in the books that the game of thrones
show did not
include um but one of the
central the central prophecy in a song
of ice and fire is the prophecy of the
prince that was promised or azor ahai
um so this is like the chosen one who is
prophesied to
defeat the white walkers in the long
night and there's a lot of different
versions of this prophecy like there's
like eastern versions that call it azor
ahai and melisandre believes that
stannis is the chosen one azor ahai
which does not seem to be going all that
well um whereas at one point maester
aemon believes that daenerys is azor
ahai and there's a lot of hints that jon
snow might be azor ahai
um so there's this whole question of who
is going to defeat the white walkers um
and they did mention this prophecy in
the game of thrones show
but they sort of forgot about it like at
one point melisandre said that oh i
think that i think that both uh daenerys
and jon snow have a role to play in the
prophecy and then it was arya stark who
killed the night king with the
quote-unquote cat spore valyrian steel
blade um but you know they didn't really
do much with the prophecy because part
of the prophecy of
azor ahai in the books is there is this
magic sword called lightbringer a
flaming sword that's gonna be
instrumental in defeating the white
walkers
um and there's all this there's all
sorts of theories about like what that
sword might be like is the sword
metaphorical and the sword means dragons
or is it like dragonglass or is it or or
is it dawn
as a valyrian steel sword called well
it's not valerian steel it's forged from
the heart of a meteor uh the ancestral
sword of house dane and some people
think that it might be the sword that
will save the world
um
what's my point my point is that it's
really interesting that they are trying
to be more faithful to the book's
version of the prophecy but they are
also emphasizing this particular um
knife and so i wonder if this knife
is meant to be lightbringer but they're
not talking about lightbringer what they
are saying is that you know there will
be there will be the prince that was
promised from my blood so like the
targaryen bloodline will produce the
chosen one who'll save the world um and
you know daenerys and jon snow are both
targaryens because john is the son of
rhaegar targaryen um from my blood will
come the prince that was promised and
his will be the song of ice and fire and
this echoes an idea that's in the
books so like in book two
daenerys targaryen has a vision of her
brother rhaegar and rhaegar says um
rhaegar had a baby called aegon
with elia martell and aegon ended up
getting killed by gravel cocaine and
armory lorch um it's not jon snow it's a
different baby named aegon
like in in the show canonically rhaegar
had two sons named aegon
one of which was jon snow like what why
why
anyway the point is that uh in book two
daenerys has a vision of her brother
rhaegar with his baby aegon saying that
he is the prince that was promised and
his song is the song of ice and fire
so what this suggests and this does sort
of fit with the book law is that rhaegar
targaryen was aware of the same prophecy
that aegon targaryen passed down to the
other targaryen kings um it seems as
though rhaegar sort of rediscovered this
prophecy in his lifetime like some of
the targaryens weren't fully aware of
this prophecy in his time and rhaegar
rediscovered it and that's why rhaegar
ran off with lyanna stark and why
rhaegar had jon snow
is because he wanted to fulfill this
prophecy to save the world from the
white walkers
and you know since jon snow is the son
of the icy starks lyanna stark and the
fiery targaryens rhaegar targaryen jon
snow is the song of ice and fire
is how a lot of people see it
um so there's a lot of suggestion that
jon snow will be the hero who saves the
world from the white walkers in the
books um
which makes it all the more weird that
it's arya stark that is the one who
kills the white walkers and like yeah
like jon snow helped but it's kind of
weird um i think that you know and you
know spoilers for game of thrones season
eight
um but in game of thrones season eight
you know jon snow kills daenerys with a
dagger and
i think on some level that echoes
the story of nissanissa
and azor ahai so like in the books
that we're told that the way that they
defeated the white walkers the last time
was that the hero azor ahai sacrificed
his wife
and that forged the sword lightbringer
um so i think that that something like
that might happen with jon snow
sacrificing daenerys potentially
um but you know that that's why it's
it's so weird that the house of the
dragon is sort of combining
the this book prophecy about the prince
that was promised
and the show did this sort of other
weird thing with arya stark and the cat
spore blade it's sort of a weird
compromise between book law and show law
and i'm not really sure
what we're meant to make of it i wonder
if we're going to get more revelations
later on in house of the dragon
that might make it make sense but then
there's also the the jon snow spin-off
show that they are
reportedly
developing
it's like what are they gonna do with
the jon snow show is the jon snow show
gonna reveal something about the white
walkers you know ooh somehow the night
king returned like in star wars nine you
know like i
i don't know what exactly like how this
is meant to connect to
the show law versus the books law um but
i mean in in terms of house of the
dragon like the reason the main reason i
think that they're talking about this
stuff
is is the same reason viserys gives like
viserys says the responsibility of the
iron throne the burden of this knowledge
like it's not just politics it's not
just who gets to sit on the throne this
is about saving the world you know so
it's about upping the stakes i think you
know they're saying that this isn't just
about our ambition this is about saving
the world that's what the throne is for
that's what the targaryen royal family
is for
so maybe that's all that we need to take
from it
thanks for the super chat from philippe
who says did you think rhaenyra lying to
alison was too sudden of a turn i think
it makes perfect sense like like
rhaenyra was being accused of this stuff
that
is politically and personally super
damaging to her like she's done this
thing i'm sure she feels some shame she
feels some guilt i mean she sees the
anger on alison's face i i think it is
an understandable thing for rhaenyra to
lie to alison and like millie alcock
said in the inside the episode
technically rhaenyra did not lie to
allison because she only said that she
didn't have sex with daemon and she
didn't have sex with daemon she had sex
with kristen cole so um yeah i think
lying is a very understandable thing for
rhaenyra to do here and i think that
that
uh tragically may lead to
you know
problems i mean i mean they talk about
this show as being like a shakespearean
tragedy you know like this conflict
feels so unnecessary but just because of
the circumstances that they're in and
the bad decisions that they make that's
what that's what sort of makes the
conflict worse thanks to the super chat
from don meza who says do you think
rhaenyra drank the moon t that the
maester brought could she get pregnant
from kristen cole yeah it's a really
good question because you know the
maester did not hang around to to see if
rainier actually drank the moon t
um it just it just cut after rainier
looked at it
so if rhaenyra does not drink the moon
tea i suppose it is possible that
rhaenyra might get pregnant with kristen
cole's bastard
and wouldn't that complicate matters
thanks for the super chat from quinovir
who says this is supposed to be house of
the dragon but
rhaenyra took the cold d
12 hour analysis on that uh that'll have
to be a i think a different channel
might might do the d analysis uh thanks
for the super chat from adam who says
any mention of verifying virginity in
the books yeah for a moment i was
wondering if they might do that because
like there is some tradition in in some
places historically i think of
inspecting a girl's hymen to see if she
uh is still a virgin
and i think that it's uh sort of an
inexact science because girls hymens can
break from just like riding horses and
stuff right
um i almost wondered yeah if they might
do that in this episode to like check if
rhaenyra was still a virgin or whatever
uh you know there's all the stuff about
the betting ceremony and you know having
the bloody sheets outside the window and
whatever um you know very invasive you
know politicizing of the woman's body
um
but yeah there is mention of that in the
books that they they do talk about
verify like maesters verifying whether a
girl is a virgin so i would not be
shocked if something like that happened
at some point in house of the dragon
thanks for the super chat from bobby who
says was there any importance to the
fact that rhaenyra had a seat and a
little stone ball at the small council
meeting did she i didn't notice that um
does that mean that rhaenyra
now like uh is a member of the small
council proper
i didn't notice that but um i mean that
makes sense as air
thanks for the super chat from lucky who
says why is it a big deal that rhaenyra
had sex with someone before marriage
can't targaryans just do whatever they
want they're politically on top i mean
that's what damon told rhaenyra like
damon was telling rhaenyra like we
should do what we want because we're the
blood of the dragon uh and damon was
telling viserys like you know we have
the dragons where on top we should not
have to answer to anyone
um and you know i mean to some extent
there's some truth in that like they can
make the rules i mean just the fact of
like targaryen incest you know like the
church of the faith of the seven
they say that incest is evil and um
maegor the cruel who we discussed
earlier
he went into a lot of conflict with the
faith because
of the ins i mean any targaryen his
predecessor had conflict with the faith
like there was this whole riot there was
this whole uprising by the faith of the
seven because the targaryens were
marrying each other's brothers and
sisters and stuff um but eventually the
faith just sort of had to accept that
like the targaryens are in charge the
targaryens have dragons and we kind of
have to let them do the incest so
there's this idea of targaryen
exceptionalism where the targaryens are
allowed to break the rules the
targaryens are allowed to brother to
marry their sisters but no one else is
allowed so like in some ways yeah the
targaryens are like a separate category
but it
wasn't easy for them to get into that
situation and it still is always a bit
of a negotiation um with the faith
um
so
you know it's always this uneasy thing
of like the targaryens are special but
it's not always accepted and and you
know like there was this interesting
moment when daemon and rhaenyra were out
on the town and they were watching this
mama's show where the mamas were saying
you know like the the common people are
against
rhaenyra it seems like from this puppet
show
not a puppet show just like a street
theater performance
um and rhaenyra said well i don't care
that they're against me because they're
not gonna have a choice that's like what
kristen kristen told rainer last episode
that the people aren't gonna have a
choice they're gonna have to accept you
as their queen and so rhaenyra sort of
echoes that this episode where she's
like well they're not gonna have a
choice i'm gonna be queen anyway i don't
care what everyone thinks
but you know the last 300 years of
targaryen history have taught us that
the opinions of the common people and
the opinions of the lords actually
matter a lot you cannot be a politician
if you're not supported by
at least some of your lords and some of
your people and having dragons
definitely means you can get away with
more you can definitely
get away with more when you have the
nuclear weapons of this world
and no one else has them but um
public opinion matters
thanks for the super chat from saint who
says do you think kristen was really
willing or do you think he was pressured
due to rainier's status yeah i mean
she's the princess so i guess you could
make an argument that he you know has to
obey the princess
um but i mean you know that's one of the
whole fundamental difficulties of being
a kingsguard i mean jamie lannister
talked about this um in the bath with
brienne
jamie lannister said they make you swear
and swear you know protect the common
people protect the king obey the king
obey your father obey the gods but what
if the gods say one thing and your
father says another thing and the king
says another thing like you can't obey
all of these different things at once
um
how can you how can you please everyone
at once i mean it's sort of like what
viserys says
um he feels like he is forever doomed to
piss off one person in an attempt to
make someone else happy you can't please
everyone and that's the problem with
power
and so yeah i mean i i guess kristen
could argue that oh i had to obey my
princess when she ordered me to have sex
with her um but i think i think kristen
i think most people in this world would
argue that kristen's foremost
responsibility was not to pork the
princess that's probably unspoken rule
one um
it is considered treason to have sex
with the princess out of wedlock and
yeah i mean
i mean rhaenyra is of age i guess is a
factor um like in this world once you're
16 or older you're considered um an
adult
um
so i guess
you know like it would be worse if
rhaenyra was younger um but yeah no
christian's definitely not meant to do
that
thank you for the super chat from sam
who says damon lying to viserys about
what happened
lends credence to the theory that he
didn't say
for a day
didn't deny it because he knew it
wouldn't matter
okay yeah so
in this scene like viserys was saying
like hey did you have sex with my
daughter um and damon yeah damon doesn't
deny it
damon doesn't deny that he had sex with
rhaenyra even though he didn't
um
so yeah i agree with you i think that's
a good point because
he just went along with this false
accusation that he had sex with the
brain era and in a similar way in
episode
two
um episode two no in episode one
uh otto told viserys
that daemon made a toast to his gold
cloaks
uh calling the dead baby balon emma and
viserys's baby son
balon
and otto said that daemon called him the
heir for a day and the way otto told it
made it sound like damon was insulting
viserys's dead baby and insulting
viserys and so then viserys confronted
daemon and said hey like you can't
consult my family i'm banishing you
um and damon
didn't deny that he called baylon air
for a day he just sort of said oh we all
must mourn in our own way your grace
but he didn't confirm or deny that he
said the thing so yeah i mean maybe
damon didn't really
intend to mock vasaris's baby like maybe
he did say air for a day but maybe he
didn't intend it to be insulting otto
just made it sound insulting because
otto wanted to divide damon and viserys
and create conflict so maybe in the same
way
viserys uh sorry daemon just went along
with the accusation that he had sex with
rhaenyra even though he actually didn't
have sex with her
i think that's a reasonable
interpretation i mean i mean damon is
self-destructive i mean look at him like
the way that he staggers into the red
keep like totally hung over i mean
similar to how his brother was doing
self-destructive drinking last episode i
think that neither viserys nor daemon
are very well equipped to handle the
power that they have i don't know if any
if any person is is really capable of
handling
uh
responsibility over an entire kingdom
and and i think both damon and viserys
turn to self-destructive drinking
um and yeah damon's
damon just creates chaos
uh he's here to cause chaos and piss
people off is what matt smith said in an
interview so we're definitely seeing
that today
thanks for the super chat from moral
support who says love the mention of
balon targaryen yeah so uh
so king viserys talked about his his
father uh king balon targaryen uh sorry
sir balon targaryen the brave who was
once heir to the throne but then he died
of a bad belly so he was only hand of
the king for five days and balon was the
guy who last rode vega the largest
dragon alive at this point and there was
this really sort of like sweet rivalry
between uh balon and his brother aemon
amon was the father of rhaenys i could
show you the family tree how about i
show you the family tree
so this guy here was balon and i liked
how viserys mentioned that uh alyssa his
mother was sort of this wild rebel
alyssa was a lot like arya stark she was
a rebel who went who went against gender
roles and she had two different colored
eyes and she loved riding a dragon and
she was uh
super cool and then she died but baylon
had a cool relationship with his brother
amon like balon was the little brother
he was the second son who was always
trying to um
be as good as his brother
um and after aemond died balon became
heir but then balon died of a sore dummy
thanks for the super chat from kpro who
says raunchy episode so far the
blackwood kid killing that lord in the
beginning is that a common thing that
happens in westeros
yeah i mean like i said it's uh it's
it's
i think it's unusual
for like major politicians to be
murdering each other randomly like
everyone acts like it's a pretty normal
thing i mean i i guess specifically
between the um blackwoods and the
brackens like these guys these two
families in particular have a long
history of rivalry
um so i guess blackwoods and brackens
killing each other is not that
unexpected but i still think it's a bit
shocking i mean the way it's described
in the book
the books mentioned that um a blackwood
and a bracken fight a jewel to the death
in honor of rhaenyra
which to me sounds like there was a bit
more sort of pomp and circumstance to it
like they actually like agreed to fight
a jewel as opposed to just randomly
stabbed each other look at this guy's
face this this guy is enjoying this so
much i love it is he meant to be a
bracken is that a bracken horse on his
thing
love it great hair great hair this guy
anyway thanks for the super chat from
russell who says love the power dynamic
shift between rhaenyra and allison
yeah there's there's they're constantly
sort of jockeying back and forth aren't
they because it was so stark in the
previous episode the way queen allison
pulled rank of a rhaenyra but now it was
like you know alison accusing rhaenyra
and um and you know rainier is alison's
loneliness sort of made her vulnerable
like it was really allison into reaching
out to rhaenyra in this scene and you
know rhaenyra was sort of
meeting her halfway and saying yeah
let's be friends again but then so
quickly it switched back to allison on
the offensive against raniero with with
the secret
so um yeah that was really fun
thanks for
the super chat from izzy who says who is
that dondarian guy next to rhaenyra um
so the lord sitting next to rhaenyra is
uh barman baratheon the lord of storm's
end
uh and it was a dondarian guy who was
describing uh how cool he is
um
but uh rhaenyra was uh not so uh into it
so uh this dondarian guy is an ancestor
of beric dondarrion who we saw
as the lightning lord who got
resurrected a bunch of times in the main
game of thrones show
that's house dondarrion and they mention
his great grandmother yeah queen
alissane they talk about queen alisain
who
like visited the blackwoods that was
something that alisane and jiharis did a
lot was that they went on these big
progresses to like travel around the
realm and to meet the lords and to meet
the common people alisaine held all of
these uh women's councils
where she like met with the women of the
realm and like ask them their problems
and how she could help them and like
that led to a bunch of
reforms and stuff like it ended the rite
of first night where any lord could have
sex with any newly wed woman um so there
was a bunch of like gender-based reforms
and stuff that happened under alisaine
and she was
widely liked
although her husband jiharis endangered
her health by having uh impregnating her
even after she had had too many kids and
her health was weak there's a lot of
like these common themes throughout fire
and blood and like a lot of the gender
stuff is a big part of the book
um and also the um second sons thing is
a big part of the book with you know
balon and um
amon and viserys and daemon and hobert
and otto and corliss and feymond that
they've added even more of it into the
show
thanks for the super chat from banana
who says that it seems like daemon
genuinely wants to help rhaenyra
experience some freedom and teach her
some things he knows about being a
targaryen i liked the conversation just
wish there was less incest yeah i mean
like at first it was very wholesome
wasn't it
um like daemon was giving rhaenyra a
taste of freedom and like he he does
have a real
argument behind that it was like damon
was telling viserys like we are the
blood of the dragon we should not have
to follow the rules that other people
follow we should be allowed to taste
some freedom and so like it almost feels
like this liberating thing that damon
lets grenier experience the world
so so there is like a positive vibe
there but at the same time he absolutely
is you know
molesting his niece to try and get the
throne and he took off her beanie
because he wanted people to see that she
was
um having sex and
therefore to besmirch her and make it
possible to marry her so
you know there are a lot of
manipulative impulses in daemon as well
as any positivity
um thanks for the super chat from
jennifer who says rhaenyra makes
terrible decisions love the agency she
has given show has added nuance to the
book material yeah i i think they have
um yeah and it is funny that like
like the the first time that rhaenyra
gets a little bit of freedom like
specifically sexual freedom she like she
like spends all her money at the same
shop you know what i mean like she gets
one little taste of freedom and she
instantly tries to bang her uncle and
then her sworn protector like she
instantly tries to have sex with like
the two people who are the worst idea to
have sex with
uh but it's like it's also like well
what do you expect
because she's a teenager who has been
given no opportunities to like take
risks and no opportunities to
express her freedom so of course she
misuses her freedom when she gets it you
know
like that's what rhaenyra has been
saying all through the series is like
you know let me participate in politics
like let me be a part of this world so
that i can learn and viserys just says
no like you will learn when you grow up
like you will be a woman eventually but
it's like how is rhaenyra going to
mature and grow into a woman if she
keeps getting treated like a little girl
and not being allowed to actually
experience things so when daemon takes
her outside into the world and just
throws her into the deep end and
starts [ __ ] having sex with her like
of course rhaenyra makes bad decisions
because she has had no experience or no
like opportunities to like gradually
learn in a safe environment you know um
like like with kristen like they made
her seem like this giddy
kid like like the smirk that rhaenyra
has and how she like playfully takes
kristen's helmet and stuff like like
she's behaving i mean i mean you know
it's flirting but it's it's a childish
kind of floating the way that she's
playing with the helmet and stuff and it
sort of feels tragic because it's like
this weird combination of like childlike
innocence
and
having sex with older men in a
politically fraught situation like it's
this it's a really complicated
social political sexual situation and
i'm sure people smarter than me will
write some long essays about it thanks
for the super chat from kaiser who says
do you think that cole didn't think he
could say no yeah i mean we talked about
this i i think that kristen could maybe
make an argument that he has to obey his
princess but i think a higher more
important rule than that is don't pork
the princess like that is rule one he's
on the king's guard it is treason to
have sex with the princess outside of
marriage
it's it's a big no-no
thanks to the super chat from nicholas
who says that rhaenyra said daemon was
her escort and led her everywhere but if
you look at the scene the only place
damon led her was the brothel yeah i
mean rhaenyra sort of ran off on her own
like after she stole from the food
merchant and yeah i mean and that's
another example like rhaenyra gets let
off the leash once and she tries to
steal from a street merchant because
it's like well whoa it's like it's so
exciting to her that she even has the
option of doing that you know and maybe
if she had had a little bit more worldly
experience beforehand she would not have
gone
off the rails as much as she did you
know like it's like a if an animal was
kept in a cage all its life and then you
let it out of its cage once and of
course it's gonna like run up the walls
and piss on the sofa because you've it's
never known how to be free you know
rhaenyra is doing the equivalent of
pissing on the sofa after
you know she's been in captivity she's
like an animal kept in captivity um so
of course she goes wild and i guess
that's you know that's also like a
targaryen thing and you know that's also
like they talk with arya like arya has
the wolf blood you know there is a
wildness to her there is a willfulness
to her so it you know it's not only
part of the sort of gendered situation
that she's in it's also just who she is
in her personality i think because you
know alison
allison has also experienced a lot of
that kind of
captivity but you know i think if she
went out on the town for a day i don't
think she would um steal food and hook
up with her uncle like you know that she
has a different personality there so you
know it it it's it's about like social
gender stuff but it's also about the
individual
thanks for the super chat from robbie
who says
not just targussi but hi twissy yeah
this oh boy thanks to the superchat from
lovely who says so did she get tea
because of damon or because they know
about kristen i i the the hightowers and
the king don't know about kristen having
sex with rhaenyra i don't think um they
just know that she had sex and they
think it was with damon so that's why
she got the moon t to cause a period
thanks for the super chat from
frostyflakes
who says can you explain how otto went
from hating on mizzaria to maintaining a
network of spies through her so yeah it
it seems that missouri's spy
told otto hightower that damon had sex
with rhaenyra and we see mazzaria
getting some money uh from otto through
her spy boy here and yeah isn't it
interesting because in episode two we
saw
otto calling mazzaria a [ __ ] repeatedly
um and mazaria said that there was you
know an implication like she's worried
that she is in danger um from men like
otto who just consider her a disposable
[ __ ] but as we learn from men like
tywin
um just because a man sees a woman as a
worthless [ __ ] does not mean that that
man won't use that woman to his own
advantage
and we saw that with tywin when tywin
had sex with shay
tywin all his life had nothing but
contempt
for
women who he saw as being low or being
sexually promiscuous or whatever but
that didn't stop tywin from having sex
with his with his son's
girlfriend shay in season four
um
so that's part of the that's part of the
whole misogyny theme is that men
disrespect women but also need and use
women at the same time
um so yeah it seems as though otto has
sort of like employed mazaria to be a
spy master for him
even though uh
they had previously sort of been
adversaries i i think it's really
interesting and ambiguous what's going
on with mazzaria because mazaria like
was
daemon's lover like what has gone on
between daemon and azaria for the last
couple years because like you know
daemon has been off at war has mazaria
sort of turned against daemon in the
meantime
because like it is an act against daemon
to tell otto that damon had sex with
rhaenyra that that gets damon banished
and mazzaria must know that so
what is mazaria up to i think that's a
really interesting question
um
thanks for the super chat from
sodom and from robert
uh who says every scene with viserys
makes me think of the sad ben affleck
meme
thanks for the super chat from brennan
who says otto getting fired when he
thought he was politically killing damon
and rhaenyra was beautiful and felt very
georgia a martin
yeah i mean look otto knew that it was
sort of a dangerous thing to have to
tell viserys that his daughter was
[ __ ] around
um
but yeah he was definitely glad to be um
getting damon uh in trouble and that
certainly worked uh thanks for the super
chat from jay birch who said would love
to see a connection revealed between the
citadel and the hightower once otto goes
back to old town
yeah i wonder if
i wonder if we will like continue to see
what's going on with
um otto hightower now that he's i guess
he's leaving the red keep now i wonder
what the
connection is now because we have seen
these two working together and there is
all sorts of conspiracies in the books
about are the maesters working against
the targaryens i wonder if otto is going
to become like
anti-viserys now more you know um
because he certainly wants to support
alison's baby taking the throne i wonder
if he's going to sort of turn against
viserys uh thanks for the super chat
from rice who says so george damon's
your favorite character huh
yeah so i mean
the publication history of this story is
interesting
um george martin didn't just write a
book called fire and blood he wrote a
bunch of parts of the story earlier on
um and sort of released more and more of
the story in in different places and the
original like story about this period of
history uh was called the rogue prince
and it was centered around daemon like
the original telling of this story of
this period that we're seeing in house
of the dragon
was was a story mostly about damon
called the rogue prince and then the
rogue prince and the princess and the
queen and like a few other bits and
pieces sons of the dragon got combined
together into one book called fire and
blood um
so i think george martin's fascination
with the character of daemon is
definitely
a big like beginning inspiration for
george about this story and it's kind of
interesting the way that they describe
daemon originally um like the
description of daemon at the start of
the rogue prince story it describes him
as as both a great man
and a monster
um
he was he was to some he was a hero to
others the blackest of villains so
admired so beloved and so reviled made
of light and darkness in equal parts i
think that was sort of george's
intention for daemon originally
but i mean and i guess it's it's
subjective but personally i tend to see
daemon as more of a villain than a hero
i mean he has
murdered a bunch of people he's started
a bunch of conflicts he's hooked up with
his niece like he's done a bunch of bad
stuff and i have not seen a lot of
heroism for him i mean we saw him
heroically slaying the crab feeder last
episode but i think it was quite clear
that he was doing that for personal
glory not to help anybody he didn't care
about that night that he stepped on like
daemon is a very self-serving emotional
dude um but you know the george's books
sometimes describe him as being more
morally ambiguous
thanks for the super chat from duan who
says do you think daemon was planning to
seduce rhaenyra since his victory or
only when he saw rainier after his
return i think that i think that hooking
up with rhaenyra has been on daemon's
mind for a while um because we saw their
intimacy in episode one when he gave her
that necklace and was very like
physically close with her like i think
that i think that intimacy has been on
damon's mind for a while
um jess asks about the baby that alison
was holding um
i i think it was a daughter who whose
name has not yet been revealed thanks
for the super chat from joshua who says
bro the 10 year old kid stormlander lord
gutted a cocky lordling in the chest who
was considerably more formidable that
was amazing yes that was amazing it was
not a stormlander lord it was a
riverland lord it was a blackwood kid
who defeated a bracken who was much
older and yeah it was satisfying because
that bracken was being extremely rude uh
to this kid and it was nice to see uh
it was nice to see him getting his
comeuppance uh but you know i i think
it's another reminder that there's a lot
of pent-up violence in this realm
there's a lot of people who want to stab
each other
there's a lot of potential for
escalation of violence because it's not
just the targaryens who have a bunch of
violent rivalries
i mean we've got a rivalry between like
you know damon and kristen
um and we've got you know tensions like
the baratheons
side with rhaenys and we've got like a
bit of beef between the velaryons and
the targaryens like there's a lot of
rivalries and grudges around that could
easily escalate thanks for the super
chat from sam who says very impressed
with emily carey who plays alison's
performance does a great job of
portraying complexity yeah i i think
alison
had a lot of feelings in this episode
and she wanted i mean she's feeling so
lonely she's feeling so trapped she
wants to be friends with rhaenyra again
but i think on some level she also
resents
rhaenyra's freedom because rhaenyra like
does all like alison feels so
constrained by rules um but rhaenyra
breaks all of the rules that alison is
at great pains to follow
um
and like it was so uncomfortable that
scene where you know alison was like
giving a sponge bath to her sick
disintegrating much older husband and it
was not a pleasant scene like it kind of
sucks that alison you know
this is the guy who she had to marry and
you know she didn't have a whole lot of
choice in marrying him it was just
declared by the king that he was going
to marry her and she was pressured into
that relationship in the first place by
her father but you know at the same time
i also like that
we had someone like kristin cole last
episode saying hey you're a princess
your life is so much better than most
people's um and so that you know and we
see the the how the common people are
just like butchered by people like damon
when they're accused of allegedly being
criminals i mean isn't it isn't it
interesting isn't it interesting that
damon targaryen and his gold clerks went
around executing a bunch of people in
episode 1 um for you know alleged crimes
um we saw damon personally kill someone
uh who was allegedly a murderer uh but
we also saw people who were allegedly
thieves uh having their hands cut off
right so it's like wow daemon demon
really cares about law enforcement huh
he really cares about laying down the
letter of the law but in this episode
rhaenyra steals from a food vendor and
daemon protects her he just sort of ah
says i'll handle it and chase is after
her so you know
in episode one daemon has people killed
for stealing but in episode four he does
nothing about the princess stealing you
know which is like i mean duh but like
it just shows that the rules don't apply
to everyone equally and i guess that's
part of damon's philosophy i mean like
he says we are the blood of the dragon
we should not have to obey anyone but
ourselves we can do what we want um he's
he's that chaotic energy selfish energy
is damon targaryen
and i think that all of these characters
have a bit of daemon inside of them you
know like rhaenyra certainly loves
enjoying a bit of chaos for the sake of
it that's why she steals that food i
don't think she was hungry i think she
just wanted to enjoy breaking rules for
the sake of it um and i think that
viserys in a way is like jealous that
you know
um daemon gets to break the rules and he
doesn't uh and you know alison would
probably love to break rules like they
do so i think there's a there's a little
bit of daemon in all of these characters
uh leonidas in the live chat says
rhaenyra was a lot more accepting of
marrying lenore compared to in the books
yeah well it's it's going to be an
interesting relationship so yeah like in
this episode uh rhaenyra targaryen
agrees to marry
lane or velaryon who is this fella who
rides a dragon called sea smoke and we
haven't seen a lot of laynor yet but we
will and um
and yeah rhaenyra seemed fairly happy to
agree to that marriage i mean she didn't
have a lot of choice given the
circumstances since you know it was just
found out that rainier had sex and she
was sort of in trouble so i think she
was not in a great bargaining position
but in the books uh
rhaenyra at first refuses to marry
lenore um
until viserys threatens to
disinherit her and make aegon heir to
the throne instead of rhaenyra so
viserys really had to like twist
rhaenyra's arm to make her agree uh to
marrying laynor although in
uh this episode rhaenyra does say i will
marry laynor if you fire otto so i think
rhaenyra feels very threatened by otto
knowing that otto told viserys about
her having sex um so
yeah i think that otto's machinations
against everyone have finally um
gone against him because you know
viserys rightly acknowledges this
episode that you know otto has been
manipulating him all along
um you know
viserys realizes that otto um
otto gave alicent to viserys as a
calculated distraction and i think
that's 100 percent true
viserys otto's plan
was to hook viserys up with allison and
you know that was in the context of
queen emma's death so it's such like an
emotionally tender
moment that otto exploited so coldly you
know
um so it does make a lot of sense that
saris fires otto i thought it was
interesting that like there were there
were a couple of moments when viserys
like
almost like questioned like threatened
to make aegon air instead of rhaenyra i
don't remember exactly what scene it was
but but viserys almost sort of went back
on rainier being his heir which is crazy
given that he just swore on his mother's
memory on his wife's memory that he
would not disinherit rhaenyra but he
seemed to be doubting it again you know
like viserys needs to commit is he
making rainier he's heir or not because
he keeps saying that he will but then he
seems to doubt it in other ways you know
um thanks for the super chat from
quinn who says sorry i came late uh but
did damon take her backdoor virginity
and kristen took her front door
virginity if you know what i mean
no
no quinn there was no butt sex in this
episode
come on come on guys we're better than
this thanks for the super chat from
mzkim who says i thought it was
interesting to see mice in the dragon
skull and then the rat above alison's
bed yes we saw a couple of mice i i
think part of what that evokes
is the idea of like rats in the walls
because it was really really cool to see
um yeah here's one of the mice who was
like sitting on the the skull of
balerion the black dread which which is
a really fascinating image um like
you've got the grandness and the power
of this dragon skull and then you've got
a little some little mice just hanging
out just having some nibbles in the
dragon's teeth
which to me like i guess that's a symbol
of like corruption like in the same way
that king viserys targaryen is falling
apart and he's like infected and
infested with like this gangrenous
you know he's disintegrating with his
fingers falling off like i think the
mice sort of
suggest rot you know corruption
um in the same way that you know otto is
sort of creeping around and manipulating
things there's also the idea of the gray
rats um so some of the characters in the
main books talk about the maesters are
corrupt and the maesters are
manipulative and they call the masters
gray rats and these are some sort of
gray mice and these are some gray mice
scurrying about looking like melos you
know so it's it's that but it's also
they talk about there being rats in the
walls of the red keep um
because there are literally like a bunch
of
secret passages um
through the walls of the red keep and
that's how rhaenyra escapes the red keep
at night time uh like i thought it was
quite funny when um you know kristen saw
rainier returning to her bedroom from
the outside when kristen thought the
rhaenyra was inside the whole time
but really rhaenyra had escaped through
this secret passageway that daemon
revealed to her and that's something
that comes up a lot in the books like
varys knows the secrets of the red keeps
tunnels and that's how varys uh allowed
tyrion to escape the red keep when he
was going to be executed and stuff and
um in the books varys brings shay into
the red keep through the secret passages
so the knowledge of these secret
passages is super important
um i've seen some people online say that
daemon targaryen must know these secret
passages in the red cape because daemon
got inside the red keep in episode 1
without king viserys knowing
but i don't think that's true because in
episode 1 they also specifically said
that daemon came in through the front
gate
so i don't think daemon did go through
the tunnels but i guess damon must know
the tunnels because
in this episode he told rainier to um go
through them anyway so yeah the tunnels
are important and you know there is a
history to these tunnels as well um
because the red keep was built
by this guy maegor the cruel who was the
king before uh jiharis
and uh maegor the cruel famously
um had the red keep made uh and then he
had a big feast for all of the workers
who built the red cape and then maegor
had all of the workers murdered
at the feast
that he threw for them because maegor
wanted the secrets of the red keep to
stay secret so he killed all the people
who knew about the tunnels so the
tunnels through the red keep are like
this
closely
closely kept targaryen secret um
although you know people like varys know
about it and varys uses the secret
tunnels for his spies he has his little
birds who are these children who spy in
the walls of the red keep for him
um and he also uses the little birds to
murder someone in the in the books later
on uh so yeah i wonder if these little
birds will continue to be important and
it's interesting that the little birds
are working for missouri now i wonder if
it's it's interesting this sort of
repeated trope of um
you know one person becomes the sort of
uh
who's that guy in uh is it the guy in
oliver twist who is in charge of all the
children all the street rats and the
urchins who work for this one guy in
oliver twist it's like that
thanks for the super chat uh from ball
and stalin who asks will they yeah well
we're not going to spoil anything
um but
george martin said that uh this
season of house of the dragon goes from
the council of harrenhal in 101 up up to
the year um 129
is uh george's answer
thanks for the super chat from courtney
who says rhaenyra swearing on her
mother's memory that nothing happened
with daemon just like viserys promising
on emma not to supplant her is it all
lies
yeah
yeah they but they both swore on emma's
memory
um which is a very like emotionally
resonant way to swear given that we saw
the death of emma in episode one um i
you know technically rainier didn't lie
because she just said that she didn't
have sex with damon and technically
viserys hasn't lied because he has not
supplanted rhaenyra but uh it certainly
does you know make it more dramatic if
those promises don't come true it's also
like the promise that viserys got
rhaenyra to promise
to
remember the secret of the aegon's dream
about the white walkers and the prince
that was promised there's a lot of
promises
and of course promises in stories are
great
because it's very dramatic when those
promises get broken in it
uh thank you for the super chat from
jose who says i think it was beautiful
that rhaenyra got to choose who she had
sex with and that it was someone that
she was attracted to yeah i guess that's
a nice sort of moment of female agency
but also like rhaenyra she chose the
person who was there you know she chose
the person who was in front of her
um
you know like like he was the one who
was convenient because he was standing
outside her bedroom you know so i get
you know she got to exercise her choice
but it wasn't the best thought through
choice i suppose
um thanks for the super chat from philip
who says that the smarter move by otto
would have been to spread the rumors
around through a third party
yeah i mean a bit dangerous to spread it
around like publicly though or like
semi-publicly like that might undermine
the whole sort of
regime potentially i don't know it's uh
but yeah i mean otto definitely could
have
used a messenger
i mean i thought it was really funny
that otto told viserys
that rhaenyra had sex with daemon and
viserys immediately responded by being
angry at otto he blamed the messenger is
what viserys did um in the same way that
viserys's brother daemon blamed the
messenger
uh in
the previous episode when
daemon beat the crap out of that
messenger sir adam when sir adam came to
damon on the stepstones and said hey
there's reinforcements coming to help
you and daemon beat up the messenger so
in the same way that damon blamed killed
the messenger symbolically viserys
blamed the messenger
uh otto in the next episode so i feel
like there's a lot of similarities
between viserys and daemon
it's just that viserys is in a different
social
situation so he has to
be more responsible since he's king
thanks for the super chat from lioness
who says that rhaenyra should have
pulled a bobby b and told the guys to
stop fighting instead of walking away it
would have showcased her authority
instead she pulled a viserys yeah i
think that's a that's a good point
because like you know the blackwood and
the bracken started fighting in front of
rhaenyra you'd think that she could have
ended that bloodshed by saying hey like
boys like [ __ ] behave by order of
your princess if you want to win my
affections you better stop butchering
each other and getting blood all over
lord boroman's floor if she said
something like that it might have
yeah
shown a bit of authority and that's the
thing like we haven't seen princess
rhaenyra really getting to
exercise her authority very much you
know she's just mostly been behaving
like a teenage rebellious girl and she
hasn't had many opportunities to learn
how to rule and if she wants to be queen
if she wants to command people i think
she needs some practice at doing that
so yeah i agree
thanks for the super chat for mzkim
uh thanks for the super chat from
imposter oak who said did she pork her
uncle or not
no she started making out with daemon or
daemon started making out with her and
they got a bit hot and heavy
but then daemon stopped and walked away
and so then rhaenyra went back to the
castle and had sex with kristin cole
instead i suppose like how how did
rhaenyra get back into the castle
because she didn't come back through
the secret tunnel because she came back
to her room from the outside so did she
just like walk in through the main gates
of the red cape did the guards just let
her in and not say yo viserys your
daughter the princess is coming back
from outside the castle in the middle of
the night
i think that might be a very small plot
hole like like how did rhaenyra get back
to the cape like remember in season one
when arya
was was doing the same thing arya stark
left the red keep
uh through the secret tunnels and then
she had trouble getting back inside
because she was wearing common clothes
and she was saying yo gold cloaks let me
in i'm the hand of the king's daughter
and they were like no you're not
um
similar thing happening now except
rainer i had no trouble getting in i
wonder how she did it
um
thanks for the super chat from joe who
says i like how rainier's amusement at
the blackwood bracken violence
highlights her immaturity and
self-centeredness
yeah i i it is pretty callous um like no
no one in that room seemed to care that
this child was in mortal combat with
with this nobleman um and yeah like you
know you'd think like rhaenyra should if
she wants to be queen she should
probably express some concern for her
people i mean alicent in the previous
episode i thought it was so interesting
that alison said to viserys last episode
hey
you should do what's in the interests of
the realm
if if crab feeder being dead is good for
the realm then you should go and make
him dead like it doesn't matter what
your personal feelings are you should
protect the people is what allison said
last episode but now rhaenyra is like
yeah i don't care what's going on
whatever
so allison seems to me like a better
queen than than rain eric could be at
the moment but uh we'll we'll see how
things develop
um
yeah thanks for the super chat from ah
and from terminally average who says i
really like this episode a lot happened
but there was practically no action i
mean there was action just action of the
sexual kind rather than the violent kind
what was your favorite part of the
episode it says terminally average
um
i mean i
i really liked i liked the bit when
everyone was friends
before everyone turned on each other
like there was this really great like i
think this scene here
this lovely like golden moment where
viserys and daemon were just being
buddies and just being bros and saying
no you were mother's favorite no you
were mother's favorite and then like
alison and rhaenyra looking like they
were gonna make friends again and that
was such a moment of hope and i think
that that was so important because it
gave us a taste of the way things could
be it gave us a taste of like oh oh like
what if everyone got along
just before everything went to [ __ ] and
they all turned on each other and
viserys banished daemon and rainier
hooked up with all the wrong people and
so i think that was a really like
tonally important moment to show us
you know how good things could be to
show us what we're missing out on when
that when they turn against each other
although like even in this happy moment
alison was looking so lonely and so sad
while everyone else was happy around her
which i think was also important because
like viserys and damon were like having
some bro time um but alison was being
sort of ignored and they and they said
something sort of rude to her didn't
they
i i think they said something sort of
mean to allison yeah would you like to
see the tapestries and then viserys was
just
viserys was just like pissing himself
laughing at his poor teenage wife who
was only trying to be polite you know so
uh and then rainier is like looking
daggers at him so you know rhaenyra sort
of took that as a moment to sort of side
with allison and look after allison so
yeah i think that was an important scene
for showing every it's showing the
potential for happiness before
everything turned to poop
thanks for the super chat from
mournblower who says not sure if it's
been said but an interesting difference
in game of thrones is having more
plotting while house of the dragon seems
to be characters acting more on emotion
first
yeah i mean i i think that's something
that can go both ways in game of thrones
and in house of the dragon i mean i i i
would note that one of the sort of first
like politically significant moments
in game of thrones season one like like
the reason why bran
gets shoved out a window um is because
cersei and jaime were boning having a
bit of twin cessed moment in the tower
and that's why brown was thrown off the
roof and broke his back and that sort of
sparked some of the tension and the
conflicts that happened um i would not
call that you know rational political
plotting i think that
emotion has been a big driver for the
lannisters
all along and i think that you know even
when it's based on ambition like i guess
you could say that otto's ambition is
you know like otto seems like a very
calculated cold rational guy but we also
see that you know he is at least in part
motivated by his relationship with his
brother hobert
and there's a bit of that like second
sun
energy
um but broadly i would agree with you
like i think broadly house of the dragon
is definitely a more sort of
intimate emotional family relationship
driven story i think game of thrones has
a little bit of a wider scope a little
bit of a broader view
um and we don't see like the emotional
motivations as much
in game of thrones compared to house of
the dragon house the dragon is
definitely more
um
intimate
thanks for the super chat from flawless
who says rhaenyra was so happy to be
mistaken for a boy yeah that's that's a
great point like there was one moment
where where daemon and rainer were like
out on the town um and someone
knocked rhaenyra aside and called her a
boy um which you know is is i mean for
one thing it's great to see her like not
being treated like a princess but being
treated like an average person and you
know some people would hate that but
rhaenyra was just really excited that
someone was treating her and
disrespecting her like like a street
urchin
and she said oh they called me a boy and
that of course is very reminiscent of
arya because i in game of thrones season
2 poses as a boy uh called arie
um she has this whole sort of sequence
when her hair's short and um
you know like it is partly a miserable
time for arya but there's also like a
sort of a
um fun and like a fantasy and an
adventure about it i mean it's like all
the
all the old stories about women binding
up their breasts and pretending to be a
boy and going off and having an
adventure and the liberation from gender
roles you know so many game of thrones
characters have that
i mean an interesting comparison
is cersei and jaime um because cersei
and jamie like cersei thinks about how
when she was young
no one could tell her and jaime apart
they were like identical twins when they
were young but then when they started
going through puberty
um
suddenly they started being treated so
differently
and jaime was given a sword and jaime
was taught to ride and jamie got to do
cool stuff while cersei was told to be
polite and say pleasantries and she was
being groomed to be married off to some
lord or something and so you know cersei
went when when cersei and jaime were
kids and they looked the same they
sometimes
switched roles and they pretended to be
each other so cersei got to experience
being a young jamie lannister and being
treated as a boy and so she got to taste
that freedom but then they went through
puberty and she was denied that freedom
you know and so i i yeah i think that's
a very sort of similar thing when
rainier is getting a taste
of the freedom of being like a common
boy
um much like arya much like cersei
thanks for the super chat uh from tom
who says i swear mum this episode is
crucial to the story
yeah it's all plot all of this is plot
uh thanks for the super chat from
frankie who says i don't get it we're
four episodes in and we still haven't
seen tom bombadil
i'm outraged that we have not had a hey
hey hey dole merry doll we're gonna have
some bombadil action at some point right
no i think that the equivalent of tom
bombadil in um
how's the dragon is mushroom mushroom is
my boy and
the moment we see this dwarf jester i'm
going to be very excited actually i
heard some whisperings that we might see
mushroom in the on the next episode
segment so maybe we'll have a glance at
that at the end of this live stream and
see if we can spot the shroom because
this guy mushroom is the guy who tells
all the salacious stories about all the
people
in this story um like mushroom is the
one who claims that um
rhaenyra did not just mac
mac on her uncle she actually uh had
weeks of sex lessons from damon because
rhaenyra wanted damon to teach her how
to [ __ ] good so that she could seduce
the king's guard kristen cole that's
what mushroom claims mushroom for the
record also claims um that alice and
hightower had sex with king viserys
before
emma died
like
mushroom claims that saris cheated on
emma to have sex with teenage alicent
um
and that was going on for a while
beforehand mushroom also claims that
alison performed sexual favors for the
old king jiharis because in the books uh
alice and like looked after and like
nursed uh the old king jiharis um before
jiharis died and viserys became king and
i think i guess we're getting some of
that vibe from allison to like sponge
bathing viserys um
in this episode like they haven't
mentioned the jaharis allison
relationship in house of the dragon so i
guess they're sort of
transferring that into
uh the allison viserys relationship
instead i think it's really interesting
how the show
often like takes bits and pieces from
other parts of the story and other parts
of the books and then integrates it into
house of the dragon so even when they
are inventing things and sort of
changing things they're still using book
material as much as they can which is
interesting but yeah this fella mushroom
has no end of salacious tales to tell
and um it will be very exciting if we
get to actually see him thanks for the
super chat from madison and from
aridrill who says which baratheon was
that at the start of the episode um the
the baratheon was borrowing baratheon
he's the lord of storm's end and uh yeah
like the the lords of the realm may be
important later on because these are the
most important people in the realm and
uh you know like mostly house of the
dragons so far has been very focused on
the targaryen family specifically
but they are not the only important
characters
thanks for the super chat from jackson
who says the moon tea is a smart way to
check if rhaenyra lost her virginity if
she drinks it it will 100 confirm it
yeah that's a good that's a good point i
guess like if rhaenyra did not drink the
tea
then that might suggest that she didn't
have sex after all so she chooses not to
drink it because she doesn't need it but
what if rhaenyra realizes that that's
what they're doing so rhaenyra might
drink it unnecessarily
uh just to make them think that like
what if she thinks that they think that
she thinks you know what i mean
and yeah again the moon t uh induces a
period so it prevents pregnancy like a
plan b sort of thing another another
thing they mentioned in this episode we
didn't see lord call us for larry on
this episode but they did mention that
carlos velaryon is looking at marrying
his daughter lena to the
uh son of the sealord of braavos which
is interesting so like corliss uh failed
to get laina married to the king viserys
um so corliss is like well if you won't
marry my daughter then i'll find someone
who will
and braavos is one of the most powerful
of the free cities in the east
braavos was founded by slaves who
escaped the valyrian empire
and so
uh viserys is worried in this episode
that if coalesce starts making alliances
outside of westeros with other powerful
people that that could potentially be a
threat to the targaryens so it's sort of
um highlighting that the viserys may
have [ __ ] up by um
by insulting corliss and not marrying
him and so that's part of why viserys is
saying hey rhaenyra you've got to marry
lenore because we've got to keep the
velaryons on our side because if they
teamed up with other people that might
uh turn people against us i really
enjoyed uh damon's entrance um
when he just strolled into the throne
room and dropped the crab feeders hammer
the hammer that the crab feeder used to
like stake people to the beach so they
drowned and got eaten by crabs
um
i like how he just dropped the hammer on
the ground and said add it to the throne
add it to the others i think that was um
that was fun it's not the first time
we've heard that barristan selmy in
episode one
threw his sword to the ground and said
there melt it down and add it to the
others so it's you know it's a reminder
that the iron throne is made of the
swords of targaryen conquests every
sword is an enemy who the targaryens
have defeated um so the iron throne is
an embodiment of everyone who [ __ ]
with the targaryens and found out
um i also thought it was uh a
notable touch that they said that um
damon [ __ ] crucified 2 000 triarchy
pirates on the beach
um
damon imitated the crab feeders
torturous execution method he fed a
bunch of pirates to the crabs
which again like hey maybe daemon's not
a good dude maybe nailing people to the
beach to be eaten alive maybe that's a
bad thing maybe damon's a bad guy guys
maybe maybe he's maybe he's a bad guy
thanks for the super chat from karthik
who says do you think otto is really
cruel and who do you think the next hand
is going to be
i'm not going to spoil who the next hand
is going to be but i hope that viserys
chooses someone who he can rely on for
unbiased advice
um no sorry i should i i'm i don't want
to spoil stuff anyway um karthik says do
you think otto is really cruel i think
it was very manipulative of otto to use
his teenage daughter alison to sexually
manipulate the king and to further his
family's interests
um there's not a lot of warmth between
otto and alison if otto does love
allison he doesn't do a great job of
showing it
um
and you know otto pushing the rights of
his grandson aegon over rhaenyra is
potentially creating divisions and
potential conflict in the realm so i i
don't think otto is a good guy no but i
think that there are definitely some
sympathetic aspects to him uh thanks for
the super chat from mick and from jacob
who says a little off topic but with all
of the game of thrones spin-off shows
which are you most excited for slash
interested in so so far uh they have
mentioned a potential game of thrones
spin-off prequel show about
nine voyages which would be like the
pre-history of the sea snake call us
about his voyages around the world um i
think that could potentially be
interesting it sounds very expensive if
they're going to show all of these
exotic places that call us sailed to but
i mean there's certainly potential for
you know adventure and cool [ __ ]
happening um
there's also the 10 000 ships which is
about nymeria who has been brought up a
bunch of times the fact that they've
brought up princess nymeria so often in
house of the dragon
that might be a hint that hbo is serious
about making a nymeria show i think
nymeria might be more exciting than nine
voyages to me because nymeria went to
sothoryos and yin and all of these super
exotic places like where there's like
lovecraftian blackstone mystery jungle
crap going on and also it's like
foundational to like dornish culture and
we're gonna see some valyrian dragon
lords and the and the rhinish water
sorcerers fighting the valyrians i mean
there's all sorts of cool [ __ ] that we
could see in
uh a show about nymeria although again
it does sound very expensive so hbo is
really gonna want to be getting their
money back on this stuff i would think
um there is also the jon snow show that
there's the it's been reported that hbo
was developing a
a sequel tv show about jon snow after
the events of game of thrones season
eight i suppose and george martin has
blogged about it and said that like yeah
this is like a real thing
um which to me honestly sounds like a
terrible idea because like
game of thrones season 8 was such a
downer and like jon snow's story in
particular because he didn't he just he
didn't really do anything except for
kill his girlfriend and then get sad and
then go north
um you know i guess he could you know
hang out with the wildlings and
maybe help resolve some wildling related
disputes i guess you could meet the
skargosi he could hang out with some
fins he could date a new redhead i don't
know
maybe they can bring back the white
walkers
the jon snow show sounds like a bad idea
to me because i just don't know where
you narratively go after game of thrones
season 8 unless it's some really sort of
like small scope drama type thing um but
george martin seems to think it's a good
idea so
hell we'll we'll find out
um what other prequels are there there's
talk of a dunkin egg spin-off show
um i would love to see a dunkin egg
spin-off show but i would like george
martin to finish the series first
because he's only written three out of
the 10 or 12 books that he is planning
to write in the series so
i would prefer george to finish the
story before we get an adaptation
uh there was also talk of like a duma
valyria tv show which apparently got
cancelled and a blood moon um age of
euros show that also got cancelled so
i don't know i i guess
i mean duncan egg even just the first
three stories would be cool but um
i don't know let let's just make house
of the dragon first and see where we go
from there
thanks for the super chat from miguel
who says do you think they want to put
emphasis on the prince that was promised
given what what happened yeah i agree
that it's weird that they're even
bringing up the prince that was promised
when the prince of the promised prophecy
didn't even really
quite seem to happen in game of thrones
season 8 when arya jumped in but hey
maybe they'll say something to
re-contextualize it later
thanks for the super chat from tyler who
says i'm surprised this show hasn't been
called woke even though it points out
the patriarchy glad we haven't seen the
show attacked
i think there's lots of people angry
about all sorts of things on twitter and
wherever but um
yeah
it's best not to listen to people who
are just being negative for the sake of
being negative
and um i'm mostly enjoying the way
they've handled the themes of the show
i i don't think it's come across as like
preachy personally like it like it's
like you know i guess maybe you could
accuse it of being heavy-handed with
some of the themes but um this has
always been a big part of what a song of
ice and fire is about you know
characters like brienne and characters
like cersei and characters like sansa
and like the
trouble they've had in societies that
are weighted against women in a lot of
ways
um
but that doesn't mean that it's just
about
um you know women having a hard time
it's also about men having a hard time
and a song of ice and fire itself you
know the way it handles women is not
unimpeachable either especially the book
fire and blood so you know i hope we can
all manage to have a opinion about a tv
show that's more complicated than just
it's great or it's bad
but you know whatever helps us sleep at
night
thanks for the super chat from my 20
somethings who says was someone watching
from the closet when she was doing the
deed
uh
i mean the orgy scene with damon and
rhaenyra when they were in that brothel
like yeah there were a bunch of people
having sex and watching each other and
it was all very
bakano is that the word it was uh i
think it was meant to evoke like an
ancient roman orgy or something like
there's lots of talk about you know
ancient rome being decadent and you know
given over to pleasure and people eating
and eating and then vomiting in the
vomitorium and then eating again and you
know some of that is not historically
true
i've heard i'm not a historian but um i
think that the show runners are
definitely emphasizing this idea that
the targaryens are really rich they're
really decadent they're really enjoying
material pleasures and material things
and i think that that sort of decadence
and arrogance comes before the fall and
before the decline um in a lot of
stories so
i think that's part of why they had this
whole the whole orgy scene going on and
the orgy was like emphasizing you know
like women having sex with women and men
with men and it was a very like
cool and progressive orgy
as far as like you know medieval
westeros goes um they seem pretty chill
about homosexuality at least in that
particular brothel um so you know
and i'm also interested like in terms of
you know complaining about workness and
stuff i'm interested if if racism isn't
going to be a theme in house of the
dragon because like the valarions being
black is a change from the books
and um in the books there are like
occasionally black characters in fire
and blood and sometimes there's like
some racism against them i mean
sometimes it's cool but like you know
like one targaryen princess like like
screams in fright when she sees a black
man and and thinks that he's a demon
because he has dark skin
um and also like the character alleras
in book four of game of thrones like
people say some racist [ __ ] to her
uh or him depending on who you think
that character is um
so yeah it'll be interesting to see how
they handle that or if they address that
thanks for the super chat from shayan
who says do you believe in r plus l
equals j
well the game of thrones tv show
in the game of thrones tv show jon snow
is the son of rhaegar targaryen and
lyanna stark that's what r plus lakels j
is
um and i think that that probably is
true in the books as well um some people
don't believe r plus l equals j and they
reckon that john is the son of like
ashara dane and ned stark or something i
think that it makes the most sense for
jon to be the son of rhaegar and lyanna
i think it's pretty clear that that is
the direction that george is going in
but i'm very interested to learn more
about what was the rhaegar lyanna
relationship what were the motivations
there what really happened how were the
danes involved i think the deans might
have been involved um so i think there's
still a lot of mystery and a lot to
learn there
thanks for the super chat from steven
who says maybe in the jon snow
seagull show they'll reveal that there's
another night king or the craster's baby
is now a new threat yeah i mean they
could bring back the white walkers i
mean the white walkers always have been
a like
recurring threat because you know
supposedly there was another long night
like this is not the first time the
white walkers came in game of thrones
season 8. it happened thousands of years
previously um it seems to be like a
seasonal recurring thing so like when
arya killed the night king in game of
thrones season 8 does that mean that all
the white walkers are gone forever or
does that just mean that this long night
was defeated you know um
and there's speculation that maybe in
the books they might have to do
something more in order to truly end the
white walker threat
um
and some people like like the youtuber
lml have theories about like
uh the white walkers are like the
the spirits of the weirwoods and they
need to like go back into the weirwoods
and the children of the forest [ __ ] it
up and there's all sorts of theories
thanks for the super chat from peter who
said rhaenys said that damon didn't
touch her which was a lie
yeah rhaenys definitely told some lies
to alison under the godswood tree but i
think when she swore that she didn't
have sex with daemon like when she swore
on her mother's memory maybe that part
wasn't a lie i'm not sure thanks for the
super chat from duan who says i think
that rainier are lying is understandable
but i'm a bit weirded out by how well
she lies
we've never seen her lie before so i
guess she's just a natural yeah well it
was so sad when alison said that it's
not in rainier as nature to be deceitful
which i think is true like rhaenyra like
what we've seen of us so far it seems
like she's a person who tends to just
say what she thinks because as a
princess you know she feels like she's
able to speak out whereas allison sort
of tries to say what's expected of her
so it's really tragic that like alison
was sticking up for rhaenyra and saying
i believe rhaenyra i believed that she
was telling the truth when we know that
rhaenyra was lying so
yeah it's so tragic um i i i feel like
you know rainier's live felt like a sort
of natural emotional
reaction like like rhaenyra seemed sort
of outraged and angry was her sort of
reaction and i think people act angry
when they feel afraid you know and
rhaenyra would feel very afraid about
this accusation so i think i think that
makes a lot of sense
um
thanks for the super chat from saint who
says every time you speak about arya
killing the night king i remember
benioff's face explaining why they did
that you know how they do like an inside
the episode behind the scenes feature at
the end of every episode to my knowledge
they never released the inside the
episode for the finale of game of
thrones season 8 season 8 episode six
did they ever release that i mean
actually yeah well i do remember benioff
saying oh i think we should have
arya kill the night king because it was
unexpected it was a surprise and that's
why they did it maybe they did release
it i don't know whatever thanks for the
super chat from dank who says now that
we know about aegon's dream do you think
he mentioned it to the starks who also
knew about the same prophecy and that's
why the king who knelt knelt
yeah so when aegon conquered westeros
he went and burned the
men of the reach and he burned the
lannisters of the west and he made the
vale surrender and he made the river the
riverlands surrender when he burned
harrenhal but the starks did not fight
aegon because they saw everyone else
kneel to aegon and they were like you
know what okay we will kneel we will
surrender and i think there is that
detail that um king tauren starks
was it his bastard brother brandon snow
and brandon went he crept over to
aegon's side and he was intending to
kill aegon's dragons with weirwood
arrows but they had a conversation and
like
there was some sort of conversation that
went on and then the northmen agreed to
surrender to the targaryens and yeah
there is speculation that maybe what
happened is that aegon said yo like
starks listen up there's this whole
white walker situation that's why we've
got to take over westeros we've got to
deal with these white walkers and the
starks were like hey funny coincidence
we are the kings of winter we also have
some awareness of the white walkers
there must always be a stark in
winterfell you know we look after the
night's watch we look after the wall
winterfell has magic to fight against
the white walkers so maybe there was
some kind of agreement maybe there was
some kind of pact device and fire you
might say and that might have been why
tauren surrendered to aegon targaryen i
think that is a reasonable theory
personally i hope that they don't go too
far in making everything about this
prophecy i like when normal human
relatable motivations and like ambition
are what drive it like i like when the
politics is about politics not all about
magic i think that like prequel stories
especially
uh sometimes make the original story
worse if they make it seem like
everything was destined from the start
and i think sometimes like the star wars
prequel shows are guilty of that
sometimes so i don't want everything to
be predestined i want there to be a bit
of free will i want there to be a bit of
chance i want there to be a bit of
normal human motivation
i don't want everything to be justified
by saving the world in the future
thanks for the super chat from zach who
says why did the gold cloak who tried to
stop rhaenyra let her go and is he
important yeah so that gold cloak was
none other than harwin strong if i'm not
mistaken
um because wasn't
yeah this fellow that's that that's
harwan strong i'm pretty sure the
subtitles say that he is yes sir harwan
that is harwan strong who we met last
episode that they didn't do a great job
of um making it clear that he's hot one
um so harwan is the eldest son of
um
lionel strong
uh
this fella the guy who was really
enjoying
uh bloodied up uh appearance after she
killed the boar that's harwan strong
called break bones said to be the
strongest knight in the realm that's sir
harwin and sir harwin now serves in the
gold clerks in the city watch um while
he's in king's landing
so he's actually like got a job in
king's landing while he's here with his
father lionel who's on the small council
um so that is why harwan let reiner go
and also because damon was once in
charge of the gold cloaks so it seems as
though there's some kind of like
relationship or some kind of
understanding there
and it's like you know when harman seems
to be once again like enjoying and
admiring rainier is sort of badassness
so yeah like i think that you know
harwan's letting her go because you know
he knows that she's the princess so
she's letting her do what she wants and
also i wonder if there might be some
kind of relationship or understanding
between harwin and damon because damon
was once in charge of the gold clerks
thanks for the super chat from
paul who says is humphrey teague the
second azor ahai definitely
uh thanks for the super chat from mark
who says when otto first heard about the
rumor the kid said it was from the white
worm that is mazaria what did mazzaria
have to gain from telling otto
yeah i think that is a great question i
don't i think that it's possible that
mazaria is trying to get back at daemon
like mazzaria told otto that damon had
sex with rhaenyra to get demon in
trouble
because mazzaria was talking in episode
2 about how daemon swore to protect her
but then daemon just like [ __ ] off to
the stepstones to have a war for
personal glory um so i think i wonder if
mazaria might be like pissed off at
damon and is sort of trying to get back
at him um but i don't know i think
mazaria remains mysterious and they are
going a little bit off the book there
with mazzaria so i'm curious to see
where that goes
um thanks for the super chat from kaiser
who says maybe rhaegar found the dagger
causing everything yeah i mean maybe but
i mean the the special prophecy dagger
isn't isn't super significant in
the song of ice and fire books
um i mean i guess it could become
significant but like at the moment the
dagger is just on little fingers in the
books so um
so i guess the dagger could have
been held by rhaegar but it's not been
mentioned thanks to the super chat from
shinobiest who says kispin up with the
targaryens
uh will cole pick duty or love
yeah well like crispin
crispin kristen cole um you know as we
talked about with jamie and the
kingsguard like like being torn between
your love and your duty is something
that george martin plays with all the
time you know jon snow had a duty to the
night's watch but he had love for
ygritte and he was forced to choose
so we can definitely speculate that
kristen might be forced to choose
between you know if he has affections
for rhaenyra and his duty to the
kingsguard
um
thanks for the super chat from darnell
cool j
and from studio who says thanks for all
the fantastic coverage
appreciate your
well-reasoned analysis thank you studio
uh sodom says i loved the nightlife of
king's landing pretty pretty great party
like is that just an average friday
night in flea bottom or is that like a
festival night i liked how there was
like a there was a guy doing like fire
magic it seemed like um or maybe he was
just playing with like some you know
explosive flammable powder like
melisandre in the books talks about how
she has like real
fire magic but she also sometimes just
uses like fake fire magic like sometimes
she just uses like powders and like
tricks and like materials that can
create the illusion of fire magic and
can like change the color of fire or do
sorts of interesting cool things so like
sometimes there's a blurry line between
like real magic and like illusions
um thanks for the super chat from
plumsify who says what was on damon's
neck yeah it looked like some scarring
or some burn marks or something on
daemon um maybe that's something that he
sustained in his battle in the
stepstones um
he doesn't seem to be limping from those
arrows anymore though
thanks for the super chat from ryan who
says that lionel strong was too
reasonable to be in this episode
yeah i love how everyone is just like
100
on lionel strong's side uh because you
know in the previous episode when
everyone was assailing king viserys with
the [ __ ] politicking lionel strong
was the one guy who was like you know
what i don't think you should do the
thing that helps me i think you should
do the thing that helps you like and he
gave unbiased advice so everyone is um
everyone loves lionel now although we
shouldn't forget that you know in
episode one uh lionel was saying hey
rhaenyra should definitely not be in
charge because she's a girl um so it's
worth keeping in mind that as much as we
might love lionel strong lionel strong
might not support rhaenyra targaryen
um
emmanuel lugo
speculates that maybe
since
mazzaria was the one who told otto that
damon had sex with rhaenyra maybe
mazzaria was also the one who told otto
about damon
giving the air for a day speech
that got damon banished from viserys
yeah that i think is an interesting idea
i think that's an interesting idea
because like in the books they they do
talk about
um
who told
the king and who told otto
for a day speech and like it suggests a
few different possible people who might
have been the person who told about this
air for a day speech um and given that
it's mazaria who tells otto about daemon
having sex with three niro yeah i think
that's a good theory maybe mazzaria told
um
told otto about the air for a day thing
although like it's weird because mazaria
was at the same time like in the next
episode telling damon hey like you gotta
protect me so why would mazzaria be
relying on daemon for protection but at
the same time be undermining daemon by
reporting all of his worst behavior to
otto hightower that um
might not make a lot of sense but yeah
she does seem to be behaving like
a unofficial master of whisperers for
sure
um thanks for the super chat from
richard cornell who says what was the
tea that the maester brought it is moon
tea and it induces a period to prevent
pregnancy
thanks for the super chat from tomi
who speculates that
the blackwood kid might have been
samwell blackwood
thanks for the super chat from jess who
enjoyed the fight
thanks for the super chat from dirty t
dirty loom who says was the plan bt a
test yeah if she drinks it that that
admits that she had sex
thanks for a super chat from duan who
feels bad for otto
sam is impressed with emily carey's
performance
and from coriander who says the business
with viserys's skin infections is
reading like meester conspiracy to me
yeah like some people think that hey
maybe
the maesters are
poisoning viserys and like causing his
uh fingers to get worse and stuff
because yeah like it doesn't seem as
though the maesters are very good at
save at like curing viserys are they
like in episode two they were saying hey
if we you know use maggots on your
fingers then your fingers will get
better but the fingers are not getting
better viserys is following the medical
advice but he's not getting better so
maybe the maesters are deliberately
making him die you know but um
i think it's pretty clear that the
maesters are working with otto like at
least grand master melos is working with
otto and i don't think it's in otto's
interests for viserys to die right now
because viserys has not named aegon air
to the throne like that's what the high
towers want they want aegon to inherit
and um
so i don't think the high towers would
want viserys dead until or unless with
sarah's name's aegon the air
thanks for the super chat from viking
raider who says what are your favorite
changes from the books
um i mean there haven't been very many
big changes from the books i mean i
i think that they've
mostly just like filled in the blanks
that weren't explained in the books i
think that damon i did enjoy daemon's
like declaration
when he was on dragonstone and when he
declared he would marry mazzaria as a
second wife and also that he
specifically stole the dragon egg that
was going to be baby balon's dragon egg
i think that was a really good way of
making
that dragon egg theft even more dramatic
and even more personal you know it seems
like exactly the sort of [ __ ] that this
daemon would do it's so
just inten and calling himself the
rightful heir like it's really balls out
it's really aggressive it's really
[ __ ] stirring and i think it's in
character and so i think that's a cool
change
uh thanks for the uh the super chat from
jesus oh jesus who says just saw the
most embarrassing thing in the episode
can't believe the blackwood kid actually
killed that guy it is a pretty crazy
violent thing to do in the middle of
like a peaceful court but that that's
black woods and brackens for you they've
been fighting each other for a long time
okay we're going to wrap up this this uh
live stream shortly thank you all so
much for participating uh i'm gonna
quickly answer as many super chats if i
as i can i'm sorry if i miss any uh so
i'll do a lightning round to try and
answer
the rest of the super chats so
kenworth says do you think the show is
doing a good job at creating grey
characters
um
and kenworth says that only daemon has
been the really awful one yeah i agree
that damon is probably the most like
objectively evil quote-unquote in the
series yeah almost everyone else i mean
even daemon like
we at least get an understanding of
daemon's feelings like like damon really
wants validation from his brother and he
feels left out and he's got a lot of
pent-up energy that he can't seem to
express and he's got a lot of
frustration and
he's got sort of you know he has a lot
of admiration for the targaryen valyrian
heritage and that makes him feel special
and like he doesn't have to follow the
rules so but yeah no i do agree that
almost all of these characters have done
good things and bad things and mostly
for understandable reasons so yeah i
think they've done a good job
uh thanks to the super chat from
amethyst who appreciated the female
director giving the female gays
and
amethyst said did you hear about the
deleted scene in episode two i heard
about the deleted scene where there was
rhaenyra helping alison get ready for
her marriage i i did i did hear about
that
hopefully we'll see it on the blu-ray
thanks for the super chat from emin who
says i feel like johnny boy coming back
to westeros could potentially be sick
yeah i mean in the jon snow sequel show
if that happens i guess jon snow could
potentially
come back and become king of westeros
because jon snow does have a strong
claim on the throne as the son of prince
rhaegar
um so i guess he could do that but i
mean they would need to bring back a
bunch of like characters from the
original game of thrones like are they
going to bring everyone back do people
really want a game of thrones 2
i don't know i don't know if people want
that maybe they do i don't know thanks
for the super chat from amethyst who
says poor alicent in that sex scene yeah
i thought it was really great how they
like contrasted and intercut how much
fun um rhaenyra and daemon were having
while alison was having a miserable time
with viserys having sex with her um like
it was such like a passionate intimate
um fun
thing when rhaenyra was walking around
the festival and going into the
secret fancy orgy and then alison is
just lying there passionless while
viserys is just grunting on top of her
with his [ __ ] disgusting infected
body and wounds on his back and all that
grossness um
you know so not only with the sex but
just like the the freedom and the fun
um that rhaenyra was experiencing while
alison was in this like cold
just dead bedroom i think was yeah i
think that was really well done
really great contrast thanks for the
super chat from gunner who says what if
the night king did an ice clone like
sub-zero and popped back beyond the wall
when he got shanked it's a mage gimmick
yeah maybe he just respawned bro he just
respawned thanks to the super chat from
amethyst who said should we keep a tally
on mushroom or the maester being proven
right
yeah yeah we we could do that um because
like in fire and blood you know the
mushroom uh jester says one thing
happened
and then the septum eustace says another
thing happened and so we could compare
you know when house of the dragon proves
one of them right we can figure out
which one of them was right more often
thanks for the super chat from
the timinator who says do you think the
new hand will be corliss or tom bombadil
um i'm pretty sure it's going to be
melisandre because she could still be
alive so i would like melisandre to be
the hand of the king
uh thanks for the super chat from jay
who says did rhaenyra tell chris kristen
that the fuss isn't about him or is he
sweating bullets right now yeah i mean
that's that is a great question like
does chris like kristen
is like how much is kristen aware
that there is drama
around the court about rhaenyra hooking
up with someone like does does kristen
realize does he know that he's off the
hook or is he terrified every night that
they're gonna come for him yeah kristen
would be very scared right now
uh thanks for the super chat from shane
who says
was it the play
that rhaenyra and damon were watching
reminiscent of the play about i that
arya watched yeah so in
game of thrones uh are i
watched a play
it was performed by
izambaro and his company and that was
about joffrey and cersei and ned and
tyrion and so she got to see the the
public's perception of of what went on
uh and she saw that joffrey was
portrayed as an innocent hero you know
so yeah it was a similar moment in the
play in this episode seeing how the
targaryens are perceived um in game of
thrones book four cersei has a bunch of
street performers executed for the crime
of insulting the lannisters with a play
so it's uh something that's in the books
too
thanks for the super chat from
mukkalukka who says no matter what
happens in the show kristin cole is king
got laid made a kingsguard able to keep
his mouth shut yeah well look as long as
he doesn't suffer any consequences for
any of his actions i'm sure kristen will
be fine
but i will remind you that the final
line of dialogue in this episode was um
was
unwanted consequences like this entire
episode is people making bad decisions
that we may suspect we'll have
unwanted consequences you might as well
call this show unwanted consequences
um
aaron says what are alison's thoughts on
rhaenyra versus her son on the throne i
mean last episode otto said your son
aegon will be king
you know don't you want your son to be
king and then alison was like uh what
mother wouldn't want her son to be king
so alison dodged the question and
meanwhile she was defending the idea of
rhaenyra being on the throne so
it seems as though allison doesn't want
her son to be king
but it's not super clear she hasn't
really totally said it either way i mean
allison might be okay with the idea of
rhaenyra marrying aegon like in the
books it was alison who suggested that
rhaenyra should marry aegon because that
would prevent any conflict between
her son and her ex-best friend you know
so it would make sense that allison
would want peace between them
thanks for the super chat from zerg who
says that targaryens are pretty saucy in
general uh thanks for the super chat
from wayne uh yes sir harwin strong has
joined the gold cloaks while he's in
king's landing uh thanks for the super
chat from gunner and eric and jess who
says the scene of rhaenyra on the boat
getting knocked over by damon
uh
thanks for the super chat from aru who
said
yep
we've already answered most of this
stuff
um
rack 9 says that the rat in the dragon
skull connects to the idea that a
thousand rats can bring down a bear
which is an idea in the book yeah
yeah well look i guess the rat could
represent like the common people you
know like the rat is not as powerful as
the dragon but there are lots of them um
so the power of the common people is a
relevant idea and the com and the power
of the lesser lords
um
thanks for the super chat from jaden who
says was the bigger deal rhaenyra doing
incest or losing her virginity confused
why viserys cared about incest i yeah i
the incest thing is not
a concern for viserys i don't think but
the fact that daemon was her uncle as in
he is someone of trust who they should
be able to trust his family and yet he
screwed her literally like it i mean the
problem is is that she had sex outside
of wedlock
if you're married it's fine
um the problem wasn't the incest the
problem wasn't even losing virginity the
problem was losing virginity outside of
wedlock and the fact that she's a
princess
uh thanks for the super chat from abadi
who says if the king believes that
rhaenyra had sex with daemon
doesn't that contradict kicking out otto
for not being truthful yeah
yeah i mean yeah i mean viserys doesn't
deny that rhaenyra
had sex or probably had sex i think he's
just realizing that oh wait everything
otto has done has been in his
self-interest or in the interest of
alison and aegon being on the throne so
yeah i mean it's funny that the one time
when viserys turns against otto it's
when otto is doing something honest and
truthful you know like yes otto stands
to gain by undermining rhaenyra but like
viserys is punishing otto for telling
the truth and i think that's sort of a
pattern that happens throughout like
like viserys mostly just does the sort
of weak like he just goes along with
the path of least resistance most of the
time and in the rare moments that he
goes against the path of least
resistance when he actually stands up
and makes his own decision it's usually
a bad decision like when he
refused to marry lena and instead
married alison you know um that was
thinking for himself for once but it was
probably a bad decision i think that's
sort of a pattern and it's also it's
it's almost like rainier like rainier
has not had many opportunities to um
think for herself so when she does make
her own decisions sometimes they are bad
decisions
um
thanks for the super chat from isaiah
who says
why was allison not pregnant in episode
four uh it's because she has given birth
alison has a daughter now we saw her
with her little daughter in this episode
it's like a year later or something
alison's now has two children baby aegon
and also a daughter
thanks for the super chat from zachary
who says when can we expect more acocca
bridged there is a youtuber
of low repute called alt shift x that
does a podcast called game of thrones
abridged that you might like to check
out if you enjoy very long rambling
drunken rants about the game of thrones
books thanks for the super chat from
g baby who says why was allison so mad
at rhaenyra
yeah i mean it's sort of like you know
it's no skin off alison's nose if
rhaenyra got knocked up um i think i
think partly it it's you know alison
feels envious at rainer that rhaenyra
gets to do what she wants but alison has
to be like trapped in this marriage and
has to follow the rules of being a lady
whereas rainier is going off and being
rebellious so so i feel like there's an
element of allison like doesn't like
that rhaenyra is doing what she wants
when alison feels so constrained
uh i think that's part of it and it also
sort of just undermines the royal family
in general like it dishonors the royal
family in the eyes of people for the
princess to have sex out of wedlock um
it creates potential complications you
know i i think part of it it's like
alison is like i'm doing my duty why are
you not doing your duty i feel like
that's part of it
thanks for the super chat from lorock
who says do you think the jon snow
sequel is george trying to fix the
prince that was promised prophecy in the
show's canon by having him address the
white walkers again i mean maybe
but like
i don't know like like george martin's
feelings about game of thrones season
eight like he has never really talked
about it
in a lot of depth i mean he has sort of
alluded to it like he has suggested that
he's not happy with parts of season 8
but he's never really like said that
outright
so if they do
do a jon snow sequel and if george
martin is involved yeah i will be very
interested to see like if he tries to
retcon bits of season eight or something
because like house of the dragon has had
a lot of stuff that
george martin is like fixing stuff that
he didn't like about the original game
of thrones like you know the colorful
dragons the colorful heraldry bringing
back jahiris ii who was one of the kings
historically that the game of thrones
show
didn't include they just like skipped
over him in the family trees and stuff
and george martin added him back in in
house of the dragons so like george
martin is in a position of more power
now because hbo is listening to george
moore they've given him more control
over stuff
uh according to interviews um so yeah i
mean if george has more creative control
maybe he'll be able to
make things more faithful to his books
but also if george is more involved in
these shows george will probably be
spending less time on the goddamn book
series that he has left unfinished for
the past uh 11 years so uh
who boy who boy let's let's hope he
finishes the wins of winter
thanks for the super chat from mark who
says we should call the moon t
plan t thanks for the super chat from
puss un puss
who says
the look that otto had after he was
fired was wild yeah look i think that
otto's actor did a great job of making
us sympathetic to a
not entirely great guy
um thanks for the super chat from
amethyst who wonders if millie alcock
had control over her nudity in the shots
yeah i um i don't know i don't know what
kind of
influence the actor has but i think
there's talk in the interviews and stuff
that we're trying to do it in a
sensitive way
thanks for the super chat from tai who
hopes that kristin cole has a strong
pull-out game i mean he must have gotten
in some practice because kristen talked
about his adventurous youth in the
previous episode so you know maybe or
maybe kristen is terrible and there's a
bunch of christian coal bastards running
around in the dornish marches that also
is possible
thanks for the super chat from inertia
who says would you not pull the otto
move if it had the possibility of your
grandson having a dragon no one will be
able to make fun of you since you have
dragons yeah
that's what all these lords are thinking
that that's why jason lannister was
saying yeah rhaenyra i could totally
build you a dragon pit all these lords
want dragons um and i think it is almost
a plot hole that like
why did the targaryens let the velaryons
get dragons
like like why did the targaryens let
lane or velaryon get the dragon see
smoke how did that happen what are the
circumstances there
um
because like targaryen power comes from
them exclusively having dragons only
they have dragons and that's why they
are the most powerful in westeros if
they let other families get dragons that
could drastically undermine their power
so yeah otto would love it if his
grandson got a dragon thanks for the
super chat from noble who says why was
the child that reported to otto also
reporting to mazzaria
uh because it looks like the spies are
working for mazzaria and mazzaria is
working with otto feeding information to
otto which is mysterious i'm very
curious to know what the relationship is
between mazzaria and otto is missouri
betraying daemon in supporting otto yeah
it seems like it
thanks for the super chat from carson
who says kristen was made king's guard
by rain era which means if she demands
hanky-panky he's got no choice but say
yes mom otherwise she could have his
head uh yeah
i i guess but like
you know he's a grown-ass man and she's
a teenage girl
uh i i think that he probably could have
left if he really wanted to and probably
should have i mean i i don't know maybe
kristen might be afraid that rhaenyra
would
say that kristen did something untoward
even if he didn't
uh i guess it's a complicated situation
but uh i think that gristin should
probably not have parked the teenage
princess thanks for the super chat from
silverscale who says i love how all the
men can subvert the patriarchy whenever
they want but they force the women to
obey because they know the patriarchy
serves them yeah well that power dynamic
is definitely
part of it and you know and in episode
one i mean throughout they they have
sort of shown how
prophecy and like like viserys's
personal ambitions are part of what got
emma killed like he said in the previous
episode that you know my desire for a
son because of these dreams led me to
kill emma by impregnating her even after
i knew that she had a history of
miscarriages and she had a history of
dangerous births so
yeah that's definitely something they're
playing with um
and vanzetti says they want george to
finish dunkin egg more than they want a
song of ice and fire yeah look i mean
dunkin egg would be cool the the dunkin
egg stories are they're fun they're more
light-hearted and it's probably more
easy for george to write some more
dunkin egg than um than it is for him to
write the winds of winter
uh all right
we're gonna wrap it up guys thank you so
much for joining in uh i think i got all
of your super chats thanks very much
um we're gonna have the explained video
out around approximately friday that'll
be the proper edited video essay and uh
press the subscribe button and the bell
so you'll see it
um you might like to subscribe to the
alt shift x podcast and the alt shift x
audio podcast there are two alt shift x
podcasts it's a little bit confusing but
the audio podcast is the one that has
audio from all these videos so if you
want to listen to the alt shift x videos
as
an audio feed on spotify or whatever you
can there's a link in the description
um and the ultratext podcast has like
some chats and interviews and stuff
sometimes you can check that out
and if you want to get a t-shirt with
the alt shift x logo
i mean look your significant other would
look great in that t-shirt so i think
you should go to standard tv alt shift x
and get one of those t-shirts wouldn't
you look great in that t-shirt
alright that's enough shilling
uh thank you so much everybody we're
gonna start working on the video essay
and uh like and subscribe and you might
like to follow on twitter
youtube doesn't notify anyone so twitter
can be a good way to be notified when
the videos come out
um
any any last minute questions in the in
the live chat i can answer
oh episode episode 5 preview before you
end okay let's have a quick look at the
episode 5 preview
so if you don't want to see the preview
teaser trailer for episode 5 you might
want to avert your eyes
but let's have a look-see
oh man
premiere is freezing up a bit all right
um so we have a marriage proposal uh i
suppose between rhaenyra and lenore
we have some valerian ships this looks
like the wedding
rhaenyra is not looking super thrilled
about being married to lane or velaryon
but she does have some pretty cool hair
heralding in a second age of dragons
that is one of the things that viserys
talked about was like uniting the two
uh dragon riding families like the you
know sea smoke and melis uh the dragons
of lanor and rhaenys will be united with
the family of cyrax and caraxies so it
does seem like a good idea to marry the
dragon riders together so i suppose this
is melis the red queen the dragon of
rainy stargaryan
there seems to be a bit of like
discoloration on her wings
um i guess that might indicate that
she's an older dragon because melees is
older whereas sea smoke is a younger
dragon it seems as though there's a
little bit of like red on sea smoke
which is a bit weird like the books
describe sea smoke as like silvery grey
but in house of the dragon sea smoke is
more red and gray seems to me
um we see the dragons we see rhaenyra
looking out over the sky like luke
skywalker i think rainier is really
dreaming of freedom you know uh we
haven't seen rhaenyra on a dragon since
episode two i think the the dragon is
certainly a symbol of freedom
uh rainey says that rainier's succession
will be challenged it's not going to be
easy for rhaenyra to take the throne
um we see the lannisters coming back
into town both played by jefferson hall
he has lord jason lannister in some drip
i was kind of disappointed um in the
previous episode
that jason lannister was wearing some
kind of drab clothes
like his clothes just didn't look like
the clothes of like the
second richest person in westeros behind
the velaryons um like this is what jason
was wearing like i guess this is like
his hunting clothes so these are not his
fanciest clothes he's got a little like
gold buckle there but i like that this
outfit looks a bit more wealthy like
he's he's literally wearing gold
like gold silk shirt or something so
that's cool that looks like hobot
hightower in the background with his
wife um so all the important lords are
coming to town to go to the royal
wedding
um
kristen cole with allison oh kristen is
looking real uncomfortable there
oh kristen's thinking like
does she know that i boned the princess
oh no
uh
he looks like a very uncomfortable man
[ __ ] um we see someone fighting someone
is that potentially uh joffrey lonmuth
and that looks like lane or velaryon
someone's fighting someone at the
wedding there's all this violence
breaking out at random times when there
shouldn't be violence um
all this pent-up aggression showing uh
and it looks like
owen strong is getting in on the action
there's a goddamn brawl at the wedding
bloody hell this this reminds me of uh
of the brawl at my wedding
um kristen cole seems to be beating
someone up uh so yeah it looks like the
royal wedding is not gonna go very
smoothly but hey it's game of thrones
you know like the red wedding was um
the red wedding was pretty spicy the
purple wedding was pretty spicy so i
think the house of the dragon wedding's
gonna be spicy too uh call us for larry
on in town for the royal wedding i
suppose otto says the king will die
oh no you don't think viserys might die
on this show do you
that that would be bad wouldn't it
uh damon wearing his hood
the hood makes him feel even more like a
teenager to me he's such like a rebel
without a cause you know he's
people who wear hoodies you know where
hoodies start fight smack on their
nieces everyone knows someone like that
uh viserys looks extremely [ __ ]
unwell
it looks like his condition gets
significantly worse and it's interesting
to see the maesters are all hovering
around him like vultures while he's
dying
um
so it looks like viserys is on the way
out and the succession crisis is looking
even worse
uh rhaenyra seems to be caught up in
this brawl at her own wedding what a way
to start a marriage uh someone's
attacking
someone i guess damon's in this scene is
someone attacking damon on the road
that's interesting uh alicent
overlooking the royal cart and otto was
telling alison to your son aegon will be
king
so prepare him for rule and allison does
not love that idea
i mean it's funny you know rhaenyra is
supposedly the heir but we have not seen
rhaenyra prepared for rule very well
have we and that's one of viserys's big
failures is not training um rhaenyra to
be the queen whereas you better believe
that otto
wants his kid aegon to be trained to be
king despite the fact that he's like
three years old so
uh
how do you give political instruction to
a teenager well we're gonna find out
uh
yeah all right um
it looks like
things are gonna start getting real uh
like all these episodes so far have been
about like establishing the
relationships creating some tension
creating some grudges
um is that mushroom is is that a dwarf
jester maybe he's mushroom that would be
fun
is it is he or is he drumming
is he is he a dwarf drummer
are they going to make mushroom
a drummer in a rock band in house of the
dragon that that would be fun
all right we're wrapping it up thank you
thanks so much like subscribe and we'll
start working on that video
cheers
you